Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. This episode is brought to you by HelloFresh. Be honest, between meetings, workout classes, and the kids' clubs, who's got time to cook? That's where HelloFresh comes in. No matter how busy you get, HelloFresh makes it easy to get a home-cooked meal on the table. With flavor-packed recipes like crispy chicken parmigiana,
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。也就是说，访问 therestishistory.com。本期节目由 HelloFresh 赞助播出。说实话，在会议、健身课和孩子们的俱乐部之间，谁有时间做饭？这就是 HelloFresh 发挥作用的时候了。无论你有多忙，HelloFresh 都能让你轻松在家吃上热乎饭菜。凭借香气扑鼻的食谱，比如香脆鸡肉帕Parmigiana（帕玛森芝士焗鸡），
you'll be filling your kitchen with the cozy aromas of a homemade meal in no time. Visit HelloFresh.ca and use code SPOTIFY for your exclusive offer. Finding the perfect gift is hard, Visit Fresh.ca and use code SPOTIFY for your exclusive offer. via SMS or email. Cressy, bringing the world's best brands to inboxes across Canada, anytime, anywhere. Search P-R-E-double-Z-double-E to shop now. We interrupt your holiday listening pleasure to bring you an important bulletin. You could be doing exactly what you're doing right now, but with bottomless bevies on a beach in paradise. With Sunwing's big Boxing Week savings, you can choose between literally hundreds of all-inclusive
你很快就能让厨房充满自制饭菜的温馨香气。访问 HelloFresh.ca 并使用优惠码 SPOTIFY 即可享受您的专属优惠。寻找完美的礼物很难，访问 Fresh.ca 并使用优惠码 SPOTIFY 获取您的专属优惠。通过短信或电子邮件。Cressy，将世界上最好的品牌随时随地带到加拿大各地的收件箱中。搜索 P-R-E-double-Z-double-E 即可开始购物。我们打断您的节日收听乐趣，为您播报一条重要快讯。您现在完全可以做您正在做的事情，但在天堂海滩上享受无限畅饮。凭借 Sunwing 的盛大节礼周（Boxing Week）优惠，您可以在数百种全包式
vacation packages that offer big value for low prices. Take it from us. We've been here since last year's sale. Hey, get away from my fries! Oh yeah, book with your local travel advisor or at... On the 25th of December, Charles celebrated the Nativity of the Lord in Rome, and the count of the years from Christ's Nativity changed from 800 to 801. And that very same day, when the king rose from prayer before the altar that stands above the tomb of St Peter, Pope Leo placed a crown upon his head, and all the Roman people acclaimed him
假期套餐中进行选择，这些套餐物美价廉。听我们的准没错。我们从去年的大减价就一直在这里了。嘿，离我的薯条远点！哦，是的，请联系您当地的旅游顾问预订，或者在……12月25日，查理在罗马庆祝了主的降生，基督降生以来的纪年从800年变为了801年。就在那同一天，当国王从圣彼得墓上方圣坛前的祈祷中起身时，教皇利奥将一顶皇冠戴在了他的头上，所有罗马人民都这样欢呼
in this manner. To Charles, Augustus, the god-crowned, great and peace-loving emperor of the Romans, life and victory. And after these acclamations of praise, Charles was saluted by the Pope in the same way that back in ancient times the Roman emperors had been. And from that moment on, he was addressed as Emperor and Augustus. Happy Christmas everybody. So what more festive reading could there be than that little reading from the Annals of the Kingdom of the Franks? And it is describing one of the landmark moments, Tom, in all history. It is the Imperial coronation on Christmas day, 800 of Charlemagne. So more than three centuries after the fall of the Roman Empire in the west,
致敬。致查理，奥古斯都，上帝加冕的、伟大而爱好和平的罗马人皇帝，愿您生命长存、屡战屡胜。在这些赞美欢呼之后，教皇以古代罗马皇帝的方式向查理致敬。从那一刻起，他被称为皇帝和奥古斯都。大家圣诞快乐。那么，还有什么比《法兰克王国年鉴》中的这段读物更具节日气氛的阅读材料呢？汤姆，它描绘了全人类历史上的一个地标性时刻。这就是公元800年圣诞节查理曼大帝的皇帝加冕礼。因此，在西罗马帝国灭亡三个多世纪之后，
the emperors have returned. There was an Augustus in Rome once again. Happy Christmas, everyone. And as you say, Dominic, what could possibly be more festive than that scene? An imperial coronation in Rome, the empire has struck back. It has indeed. So as you prepare your sprouts and do your turkey and all that kind of stuff, I hope that you will enjoy our explanation of what the hell is going on here. So in the previous episode, we heard about Charles' rise to greatness, how he comes to be Charles the Great, Carolus Magnus Charlemagne, as he's known in English. And he commands by far the most potent war machine in Europe.
皇帝们回归了。罗马再次迎来了奥古斯都。大家圣诞快乐。正如你所说，多米尼克，还有什么能比那个场景更具节日气氛呢？罗马的帝国加冕礼，帝国反击战。确实如此。因此，当你们准备抱子甘蓝、烤火鸡以及所有这些东西的时候，我希望你们能喜欢我们对这到底是怎么一回事的解释。所以在上一集中，我们听到了查理的崛起，他是如何成为伟大的查理，即英语中所知的查理曼（Carolus Magnus Charlemagne）的。他指挥着欧洲最强大得多的战争机器。
He has extended his empire beyond the Pyrenees in the west and eastwards into what is now Hungary and all the way up to the river Elbe in the north of Germany. He has sponsored a great program of education and learning. He's a very, very formidable figure. People may wonder, well, if a man like this wants to be emperor, why not? Why shouldn't he be? Go ahead. Yeah. But the thing is, of course, Charlemagne is not the only player in this particular game. So mentioned in that passage that you read, Dominic is another key player. And that is the man referred to as Pope Leo. And this is the first time we've heard of him. So who is he? It's worth diving
他的帝国在西方超越了比利牛斯山脉，向东延伸至如今的匈牙利，一直延伸到德国北部的易北河。他资助了一个伟大的教育和学习计划。他是一个非常非常令人生畏的人物。人们可能会想，如果这样一个人想成为皇帝，为什么不呢？为什么他不能呢？请讲。是的。但问题是，当然，查理曼并不是这场特定博弈中唯一的玩家。多米尼克，你刚才读的那段话中提到了另一个关键玩家。那个人就是被称为教皇利奥的人。这是我们第一次听到他的名字。那么他是谁呢？我认为值得深入了解
into his backstory, I think, because according to a key source, the whole idea of this coronation, this proclamation of Charlemagne as Augustus, as emperor, was his and his alone. This key source is one that we've been referring to a number of times over the course of this series and that is Einhard, the biographer of Charlemagne. And in his biography, Einhard writes, Charles made it clear that he would never have entered the cathedral that Christmas day, even though it was the greatest of all the festivals of the church, had he only known in advance what the Pope was planning to do. So in other words, if Einhard is to be trusted when he says this, when Charlemagne goes in and the Pope kind of plonks the crown on his head and hails him as Augustus, Charlemagne
他的背景，因为根据一个关键消息来源，这次加冕以及将查理曼宣告为奥古斯都、为皇帝的想法完全是他一个人的主意。这个关键消息来源正是我们在本系列节目中多次提到的人，即查理曼的传记作家艾因哈德（Einhard）。艾因哈德在传记中写道：查理明确表示，如果他早知道教皇的计划，即使那是教会最盛大的节日，他也绝不会在那个圣诞节进入大教堂。换句话说，如果艾因哈德的这番话值得信赖，那么当查理曼进去而教皇把王冠戴在他头上并欢呼他为奥古斯都时，查理曼
is taken completely by surprise. It's come as a total bombshell. I mean, who knew this was going to happen? Yeah. I mean, it's intriguing. Is this likely? Is this plausible? And I think that's what we're going to explore now.
完全被打了个措手不及。这简直是一个惊天大炸弹。我的意思是，谁能料到会发生这种事？是的。我的意思是，这很耐人寻味。这可能吗？这合理吗？我想这正是我们接下来要探讨的内容。
Did it come as a complete surprise to Charlemagne or was it actually basically his idea? Okay. So in the last episode, the Pope was called Hadrian. That's right. And now we've got a new character, but get Hadrian off the stage, Tom. So Hadrian was a kind of Roman patrician kind of character, which I guess so many popes were in these days. Hence his name. He got a Roman name. He has, yes. So after the great emperor. And as you say, most popes at this point are from the Roman nobility. Hadrian is a, you know,
这对外公查理曼来说完全是个意外，还是说这其实基本上就是他的主意？好的。所以在上一集中，教皇名叫哈德良（Hadrian）。没错。现在我们有了一个新角色，不过让哈德良退场吧，汤姆。所以哈德良是一个类似罗马贵族的人物，我想那时的许多教皇都是如此。因此他得名。他有一个罗马名字。他确实有，是的。所以在伟大的皇帝之后。正如你所说，此时大多数教皇都来自罗马贵族。哈德良是一个……
he'd been a kind of a subtle, clever political operator. He was the guy who had got Charlemagne to come down and conquer the Lombards and kind of remove that threat to the autonomy of the papacy. He'd been a good Christian, a good pope in that sense, built lots of churches, but he'd also been a good administrator of Rome in a slightly older sense, a more Caesar-style sense. So he'd repaired the city walls, for instance, and he'd also renovated the four main aqueducts that brought water into the heart of Rome. So in that sense, a secular figure, and even more so because he does what Roman nobles
他一直是一个狡猾、聪明的政治操作手。正是他让查理曼南下征服伦巴第人，并解除了对教皇国自治的威胁。从这个意义上说，他是一个好的基督徒、一个好的教皇，建造了许多教堂，但从一个稍微古老、更具恺撒风格的意义上来说，他也是罗马的一个优秀的行政管理者。例如，他修复了城市城墙，还修复了将水引入罗马市中心的四条主要引水渠。从这个意义上说，他是一个世俗人物，而且更是如此，因为他做了罗马贵族
generally do, even if they're Pope, which is to shamelessly advance his own relatives. So all his kind of various cousins and brothers and so on have been given plum positions in the administration of the city. And when he dies in 795, again on Christmas day. So today back in 795, the vote unexpectedly for Pope doesn't go to a Roman, but goes to a man of relatively humble background from the south of Italy. And this is the guy who takes the name of Leo the third and his election has been unanimous, but out in the, you know, the halls and the villas of the Roman aristocracy, there's consternation, because you don't want some bloke from the south of Italy turning up. Right.
通常会做的事，哪怕他们是教皇，那就是毫不羞耻地提拔自己的亲戚。因此，他所有的表亲、兄弟等等都在城市行政管理中被委以要职。当他在795年去世时，又是在圣诞节。所以就在795年的今天，教皇的选举意外地没有落入罗马人之手，而是落入了一位来自意大利南部、出身相对卑微的男子手中。这就是被称为利奥三世（Leo III）的人，他的选举是全票通过的，但在罗马贵族的厅堂和别墅里，却是一片惊恐，因为你可不希望某个来自意大利南部的家伙跑来。对。
His apavani. Yeah. I'm putting his oar into the local government. And the people, obviously, who particularly resent this are Hadrian's relatives, because they've not only lost their patron, but they've got this guy coming in and trying to do reforms and bringing his own people in. And this is a problem because they are still in control of large amounts of the administration of Rome. And so Leo, who knows that he has a problem here, unsurprisingly, is very, very keen to get on the right side of Charlemagne, who's a kind of brooding presence
他的乡巴佬。是的。对地方政府指手画脚。显然，对此最愤恨的人是哈德良的亲戚，因为他们不仅失去了靠山，还迎来了这个试图进行改革并安插自己亲信的家伙。这是一个问题，因为他们仍然控制着罗马的大量行政管理权。因此，深知自己面临麻烦的利奥，毫不奇怪地非常非常渴望博得阿尔卑斯山以北那个虎视眈眈的存在——查理曼的好感。因此，他一当选就确保派出一名信使前往法兰克国王那里，正式宣布自己当选为教皇。现在，利奥没有做的一件事——而他的前辈们在直到大约50年前的一段时间里一直在做——就是派信使去君士坦丁堡，告诉那位作为君士坦丁大帝继承人在那里统治的罗马皇帝，他已经当选为教皇。所以他没有这样做。不，他没有这样做。当然，自从西方帝国
north of the Alps. And so he makes sure the moment he's been elected to send a messenger to the King of the Franks and formally announce that he has been elected Pope. Now, what Leo does not do, which his forebears had been doing for a fair old time until about 50 years previously, is send a messenger to Constantinople to tell the Roman emperor in Constantinople, who rules there as the heir of Constantine, that he's been elected pope. So he doesn't do that. No, he doesn't do that. And of course, the emperor in Constantinople, since the collapse
崩溃以来，也就是自476年以来，君士坦丁堡的皇帝一直是唯一的罗马皇帝。教皇传统上一直视自己为君士坦丁堡罗马皇帝的臣民。而且因为君士坦丁堡的皇帝可以声称自己继承了罗马帝国——我的意思是，从某种意义上说，这就是罗马帝国，从未中断过——君士坦丁堡人们的习惯是用一种相当傲慢甚至常常是轻蔑的态度来看待西方的领导人。所以教皇首先显然是一个非常重要的人物，甚至连君士坦丁堡的人也承认这一点，但他传统上一直被视为君士坦丁堡罗马皇帝的臣民，而不是法兰克国王的臣民，而法兰克国王基本上就是他现在所依附的对象。因此，过去罗马教皇与君士坦丁堡皇帝之间的这种联盟，现在已经变成了罗马教皇与法兰克国王之间的联盟。当然，君士坦丁堡的人对此感到非常痛苦和愤恨。此外，传统上，拜占庭人、君士坦丁堡的罗马人一直认为法兰克人基本上只是一群野蛮人。
of the empire in the west, so since 476, he's been the only Roman emperor there is. And the pope traditionally had always seen himself as a subject of the Roman Emperor in Constantinople. And because the Emperor in Constantinople can lay claim to the inheritance of the Roman Empire, I mean, in a sense, you know, it is the Roman Empire, there's never been a break. The habit of people in Constantinople is to look on leaders in the West with a fair measure of auteur and often contempt. So the Pope first, obviously a very significant figure and acknowledged as such even by people in Constantinople, but he has traditionally been viewed as a subject of the Roman Emperor in Constantinople and not of the King of the
并以一种非常帝国主义的方式对待他们。因此，如果他们表现得好，就会赐予他们美好的头衔、长袍和各种诸如此类的东西。但如果可能的话，他们也会确保抓住法兰克王室的成员，把他们当作人质关在君士坦丁堡，以此作为他们行为良好的担保人。因此，他们习惯于认为法兰克国王在任何意义上都是平等的，更不用说高人一等了。从君士坦丁堡的角度来看，法兰克国王和教皇基本上都是些土包子、乡下人。是的。谁在乎西方呢？那是个落后地区，不是吗？几个世纪以来，它一直是个落后地区。所有的行动、所有的财富、所有的魅力、所有的老练都在东地中海。谁在乎这些基本上毛发浓密的野蛮人呢？对于君士坦丁堡的人来说，法兰克人依然某种程度上是野蛮人，不是吗？然而，正如你在前几集所描述的那样，查理曼是一个不同级别的军阀，因为他实在强大太多了，他的领土大得多，他的军事
Franks, which is essentially what he's become. So this alliance that previously had been between the Pope in Rome and the emperor in Constantinople has now become an alliance between the Pope in Rome and the Frankish king. And of course, the people in Constantinople are very bitter and resentful about this. Also, traditionally, the Byzantines, the Romans of Constantinople have viewed the Franks as basically just barbarians. And treated them in a very kind of imperial manner. So if they behave well, they'll give them nice titles and robes and various things like that. But they also make sure if they possibly can to grab members of the Frankish royal family, keep them as hostages in Constantinople as guarantors of good behaviour. So they are not in the habit of viewing the Frankish king
机器也令人印象深刻得多。那么，君士坦丁堡的罗马皇帝是否以不同于他的前任、不同于以往法兰克国王的方式对待他呢？我认为他们是这样的，我认为这不仅反映了法兰克人的强大，也反映了拜占庭的虚弱。帝国一直在经历法兰克人的强大，但也伴随着拜占庭的虚弱。帝国一直在经历一个非常艰难的阶段。它的辉煌似乎大打折扣，尤其是与查理曼的领土相比。事实上，在781年，拜占庭皇帝君士坦丁六世（Constantine VI）曾与查理曼的一个女儿订婚。这是一种长期的投资，因为当时君士坦丁六世只有10岁，查理曼的女儿只有6岁。所以这场婚礼将在
as in any way an equal, still less a superior. And essentially seen from Constantinople, both the Frankish king and the Pope are kind of, you know, they're rubes, they're hicks. Yeah. Who cares about the West? It's a backwater, isn't it? It's always been a backwater for centuries. All the action, all the wealth, all the glamour, all the sophistication is in the Eastern Mediterranean. Who cares what these basically hairy barbarians, they're still kind of barbarians, the Franks to the people in Constantinople, aren't they? However, Charlemagne, as you described in the previous episodes, is a warlord of a different order because he is just so much more powerful and his realm is so much greater and his military
以后举行。但到了787年，是查理取消了这桩婚约。这真的冒犯了拜占庭人的自尊心（Amor Propera）。他们对此感到非常被惹恼。君士坦丁的母亲伊琳娜（Irene）当时就在现场，对此勃然大怒。多米尼克，是你把伊琳娜引入《历史的其余部分》的，对吧？我想，是在第二季的《爱情岛》里吗？她是那里的参赛选手。你还记得吗？真的吗？汤姆，我甚至都不记得了。那是好久以前的事了。我想你确实提过。我们做过那么多节目了。我对此完全没有记忆。
machine is so much more impressive. So do the Roman emperors in Constantinople, do they treat him differently from his predecessors, from previous Frankish kings, would you say? I think they do and I think it reflects not just Frankish strength but also a Byzantine weakness. The empire has been going through a Frankish strength, but also a Byzantine weakness. The empire has been going through a very rough stage. Its glory seems very diminished and particularly in contrast to Charlemagne's realm. And so in fact, in 781, the Byzantine emperor Constantine VI had been betrothed to one of Charlemagne's daughters. And this was a kind of long-term investment because Constantine VI was only 10 at the time and Charlemagne's daughter was only six. So the wedding was going to
所以你就像上一集里的那个神父。忘了。是的，忘了自己教过的一切。忘了自己学过的一切。是的。好吧，既然如此，我就简单勾勒一下伊琳娜的概况。非常了不起。她来自一个非常贵族的雅典家庭。她来到君士坦丁堡。她让她的丈夫黯然失色。她让她的儿子黯然失色。她基本上是作为与她儿子共同执政的共治女皇在统治。而且她非常非常为她儿子鸣不平。第二年，她向查理曼发送了一个信号，表明她不会被人欺负：她派遣了一支远征军
happen down the line. But then in 787, it's Charles who cancels the engagement. So this really offends Byzantine Amor Propera. They're very offended by this. Constantine's mother, Irene, who is very much on the scene is furious about this. And Dominic, you introduced Irene onto the rest of this history, didn't you? In I think, was it the second Love Island? She was a contestant on that. Do you remember that? Really? I don't even remember that, Tom. So long ago. I think you did. We've done so many episodes. I have no recollection of that whatsoever.
前往意大利南部，这显然在法兰克人的势力范围内，但传统上也被拜占庭人所占据。因此，这被查理曼视为一种敌对行动。而当利奥三世成为教皇后，却疏忽了将自己的当选通知伊琳娜和君士坦丁六世，这无疑是在伤口上撒盐。接着在797年，君士坦丁堡发生了一场非常戏剧性的危机，因为问题在于君士坦丁六世基本上毫无用处。他在政治上很不成熟（maladeur）。他很冲动。他很残忍。他是一个非常令人讨厌的年轻男子。甚至连伊琳娜也这么认为。因此她采取了非常严厉的措施。而拜占庭编年史家狄奥凡尼斯（Theophanes）告诉了我们这些严厉的措施是什么，他写道：在800年8月15日，
So you're like that priest in the previous episode. Who's forgotten. Yeah, forgotten everything he ever taught. Forgotten everything he ever learned. Yeah. Well, in which case, I will just give you a quick sketch of Irene. Very formidable. She's from a very aristocratic Athenian family. She's come to Constantinople. She put her husband in her shadow. She's put her son in her shadow. She is essentially ruling as co-empress with her son. And she's very, very indignant on his behalf. And the following year, she sends a kind of marker to Charlemagne that she's not going to be pushed around by sending an expeditionary
797年，皇帝君士坦丁六世在其母亲及其谋士的授意下，为了杀死他，遭到了可怕且无可挽回的弄瞎双眼的惩罚。通过这种方式，他的母亲伊琳娜夺取了权力。因此，来自君士坦丁堡恺撒宫廷的育儿秘诀——对待不听话的孩子采取了非常粗暴的方法。正因如此，伊琳娜成为了罗马历史上第一位、事实上也是唯一一位统治女皇。君士坦丁堡勉强承认了这一点，但在其他地方，有人觉得，你不能让一个女人统治罗马帝国。事实上，她并没有维持多久，对吧？她并没有维持多久。朱迪思·赫伦（Judith Heron）写过一本关于她的精彩著作《穿紫袍的女性》（Women in Purple）。
force to southern Italy, which is obviously in the Frankish sphere of influence, but also traditionally has been occupied by the Byzantines. So it's interpreted by Charlemagne as a hostile move. And when Leo III, having become Pope, then neglects to inform Irene and Constantine VI of his election, it kind of rubs salt in the wound. And then in 797, there is a really spectacular crisis in Constantinople because the problem is that Constantine VI basically is useless. He is politically maladeur. He is impulsive. He's cruel. He's a very unpleasant young man. And even Irene thinks this. And so she takes very firm measures. And we're told what these firm measures were by the Byzantine chronicler Theophanes, who writes, on the 15th of August,
是的。一本非常好的书。但在西方，基本上大家的假设是她并没有穿上紫袍，她不可能这样做，因为她是个女人，因此恺撒的宝座空悬着。这对某个自认为有点儿皇帝风范的人来说是个绝佳的机会。你可能会这么想。而且更是如此，因为在罗马，就像在新罗马一样，一场危机正在酝酿。这也是一场根据某些消息来源将涉及弄瞎双眼的危机。基本上，其背景就是罗莎蒙德·麦基特里克（Rosamund McKitterick）在她最近关于查理曼的书中所谓的罗马肮脏的地方政治。这一切都是关于地方派系斗争。这一切都是关于哈德良的亲戚对这个空降并插手地方事务的外来教皇的怨恨。巴伦先生 所以这仍然在暗中酝酿，对吧？巴伦先生 这绝对仍在暗中酝酿。在797年4月25日，也就是君士坦丁堡可怜的君士坦丁六世被他妈妈弄瞎眼睛的同一年，教皇在骑马离开宫殿前往弥撒时遭到伏击，伏击他的人是暴徒，他们是由
797, the Emperor Constantine VI was terribly and irrevocably blinded by the will of his mother and her counselors with the intention of killing him. In this way, his mother, Irene, took power. So parenting hints from the court of the Caesars in Constantinople, a very robust approach to disobedience from children. And as a result of this, Irene becomes the first and in fact, the only ruling empress in the whole sweep of Roman history. And she is acknowledged as such grudgingly in Constantinople, but elsewhere there are people who feel, well, you can't have a woman ruling the Roman Empire. And in fact, she doesn't last that long, does she? She doesn't last that long. There's a brilliant book on her by Judith Heron, Women in Purple.
已故教皇哈德良的亲属雇佣的。我们有一份相当详细的记录，对利奥非常有利，写于他死后。其中描述了教皇被从马背上拽下来，他身上的衣服被扒光，袭击者试图挖出他的眼睛并割掉他的舌头。然后他们把他拖到一个紧挨着祭坛的修道院里，再次弄瞎了他的眼睛，割掉了他剩下的舌头。等等，他们此时把他的眼睛弄瞎了两次吗？他的眼睛确实被弄瞎了，对吧？这不清楚。我的意思是，似乎第一次弄瞎眼睛的尝试没有成功。我的意思是，我不知道你怎么能——如果你真的铁了心要弄瞎某人的眼睛，这似乎很容易。
Yes. Really good book. But in the West, essentially the assumption is that she has not adopted the purple, that she can't have done because she's a woman, and that therefore the throne of the Caesar sits vacant. Nice opportunity there for somebody who fancies himself as a bit of an emperor. You might think that. And all the more so because in Rome, as in the new Rome, a crisis brewing. And this too is a crisis that according to some sources will involve a blinding. And essentially the context for this
得了吧。这没那么复杂。不管怎样，他的眼睛确实瞎了，或者说真的瞎了吗？他的情况非常糟糕，并在罗马被他的敌人正式废黜。他被指控犯有通奸罪和作伪证罪，随后被带到一个修道院并锁了起来。但随后，多米尼克，一个绝对的奇迹——这被记录在他的生平中：恰逢通过上帝的先知和行动，利奥恢复了视力，他的舌头也恢复了，因此他能够说话。太神奇了。他又看得见、说得了话了。
is what Rosamund McKitterick in her recent book on Charlemagne describes as the squalid local politics of Rome. And it's all about local faction fighting. It's all about the resentment of Hadrian's relatives at this Parvenu pope who's come in and is sticking his oar in. Will Barron So that's still simmering, right? Will Barron That's absolutely still simmering. And on the 25th of April, 797, so that's the same year that in Constantinople, poor old Constantine the Sixth is being blinded by mum. The Pope is ambushed as he rides out of his palace to go to mass and the people ambushing him are thugs who have been hired
在我听来，他们当时无论是挖眼睛还是割舌头，大概都没有做得十分称职，因为我不相信那些器官能重新长出来。不管怎样，或者也许这一切都是编造的。也许吧，是的。不管怎样，他基本上逃离了罗马。他被驱逐出罗马，当然，他去见了一个显而易见的人，那就是法兰克与伦巴第国王、罗马人的贵族查理大人。所以他基本上投向了查理曼的怀抱，对查理曼说：帮我一把吧。是的。随着他的离去，关于所发生事情的消息自然在他前方传开。
by the late Pope Hadrian's kinsmen. And we have a quite detailed account, very favorable to Leo, written after his death. And it describes how the Pope has pulled off his horse, he has all his clothes ripped off him, his assailants try to put out his eyes and to cut out his tongue. They then drag him into a monastery right in front of its altar and again, they blind him, they hack out what remains of his tongue. So hold on, they blinded him twice at this point. He's definitely been blinded, right? It's unclear. I mean, it seems that the first attempt at blinding didn't work. I mean, I don't know how you could, if you really set on blinding someone, it seems quite easy.
必须承认，同情之声压倒性地站在他这一边。甚至在教皇到达查理曼那里之前，就有人说：哦，等等。我们得到这些报告说他的眼睛被弄瞎了，然后舌头被拔了出来。现在我们听说他又能看又能说了，这到底是怎么回事？也许这里面有点夸大其词吧。但当然，当利奥见到查理曼时，他受到了极大的同情。而由于某种不幸的巧合，自称是君士坦丁堡女皇的伊琳娜的使节——但在西方许多人看来，她根本不是什么女皇——也和查理曼在一起。你会有一种感觉，查理曼已经成为了罗马皇帝和教皇的仲裁者。你知道，这两个曾经将法兰克国王视为彻头彻尾暴发户的令人敬畏的人物，而他却在帕德博恩（Paderborn）这个新鲜而粗糙的堡垒里迎接他们——这座堡垒是在770年代建立的，作为进行萨克森战争的基地，但查理曼就在前一年将其建立为主教区。所以你可以看到他在古代世界的领导者们面前将自己展现为一个充满活力、锐意进取的形象，在那些从未被古代罗马人征服过的蛮荒之地竖起防御工事和教堂。这非常非常令人印象深刻。因此，他作为军阀的威名正被大力推到
Yeah, come on. It's not that complicated. But anyway, he's definitely blinded, or is he? And he's in a terrible way and he gets formally deposed by his enemies in Rome. He's accused of adultery and perjury, and he's then taken off to a monastery where he's put under lock and key. But then Dominic, an absolute miracle, so it's recorded in his life. It happened that through God's foreknowledge and action, Leo recovered his sight and his tongue was restored to him so he could speak. So amazing. He can see and he can talk again.
拜占庭使节和教皇本人面前。现在，教皇和查理曼讨论了什么，我们不得而知。我们没有记录，但他仍然非常紧跟地缘政治的脉搏。在 papal 和拜占庭使节到达之前，他给查理写了一封信。他在信中指出，正在发生的事情是多么非同寻常。因为正如他所说，上帝委派统治世界的最高权威有三位。这些就是教皇、第二罗马（即君士坦丁堡）的皇帝，以及查理曼本人。他说，你知道，教皇卷入了丑闻。君士坦丁堡的皇帝是个女人。这赋予了你对上帝的巨大责任，去为基督教人民做正确的事。他说，阿尔琴（Alcuin）具体这样说过，基督教人民依靠你权力的卓越、你智慧的光芒以及
Sounds to me that they had probably not done a very competent job of either the gouging of the eyes or the severing of the tongue, because I don't believe those things could grow back. Anyway, or perhaps it was all made up. Well perhaps, yeah. So anyway, he flees Rome basically. He's exiled from Rome and of course, he goes to see the obvious person, which is, I read, the Lord Charles, King of the Franks and Lombards and Patrician of the Romans. So he basically throws himself on Charlemagne's, says to Charlemagne, give me a hand here. Yes. And as he goes, of course, the news of what's been happening ripples out before him.
你作为统治者的尊严的高度。看啊，整个基督教会残破不堪的健康状况，唯独寄托在你的身上。很难想象这封信的含义不在查理曼在帕德博恩与教皇协商时的大脑中占据重要地位。压力不大，但他在这里有一个绝佳的机会，对吧？因为基本上另外两个权威人物都已经蒙羞了。悬在他们头上的可以说是满腹疑问。当然，这个疑问是一个加洛林式的创新。因此，查理曼在这里有一个机会，真正将自己确立为“同辈中的首席”（Primus Inter Pares），对吧？所有这些角色中最重要的人物。是的。因此，两三年过去了，我们现在来到了公元800年的夏天。所以是世纪之交。那个夏天，我认为这真的很能说明问题。查理曼决定向西前往图尔（Tours），阿尔琴当然是那里的修道院长。他在那里与他的儿子们举行了一次峰会。所以，他在与他的伟大老师和顾问协商。他在与他的儿子们协商。当然，他有机会去圣马丁神殿祈祷，圣马丁是法兰克人所有守护圣人中最重要的一位。然后他前往巴黎，那是克洛维（Clovis）的首都，克洛维是第一位皈依基督教的法兰克国王。有趣的是，正当我们录制这集节目时，巴黎圣母院刚刚重新开放。在巴黎圣母院前，有一尊查理曼的巨大骑马雕像。我想他正挥舞着宝剑。但这却是查理曼对法兰克古代首都的唯一一次访问。不过再次让你觉得，他是否在去那些在法兰克历史上具有重要意义的地方，因为他正在为一项轰动的创新做准备？他希望得到保证，自己拥有上帝和某种法兰克历史的支持。无论如何，不管怎样，秋天现在开始逼近。于是他向南进发，前往拉韦纳（Ravenna），这同样是一座具有重大历史意义的城市。是的，当然。你知道，它曾是西罗马帝国最后几位皇帝的驻地。那是拜占庭意大利总督的首都所在地。所以，这同样是一个沉浸在西方罗马帝国主义理想中的地方。然后他穿过亚平宁山脉，接近罗马，并在公元799年11月23日，在距离罗马约15英里处遇到了教皇利奥。
And it has to be said that sympathies are overwhelmingly on his side. Even before the Pope has reached Charlemagne, there are people saying, oh, well, hold on. We've got these reports that he's been blinded and then his tongue pulled out. And now we gather that he can see and talk what's going on there. Perhaps there's a bit of exaggeration going on here. But certainly when Leo reaches Charlemagne, he's greeted with great sympathy. And by a kind of unfortunate coincidence, ambassadors from Irene, who claims to be the Empress of Constantinople, but in the opinion of lots of people in the West, isn't an Empress
据编年史家记载，他受到极其尊贵的款待。第二天，他以极其华丽的姿态进入了罗马。我们不知道他带了多少人，但毫无疑问，这是一支令人印象深刻且望而生畏的随从队伍。所以查理曼现在在罗马了。距离圣诞节还有一个月。摆在查理曼和教皇面前最紧迫的问题，是如何处理对利奥的指控。幸运的是，对利奥而言，也可能对查理曼而言，阿尔琴准备了一份法律辩护词，论证教皇不能受审，因此利奥的政敌们对他的通奸和作伪证指控基本上被扫进地毯下。太棒了，一切焕然一新，利奥随时准备出发。这就是公元800年圣诞节加冕礼的背景。
at all, they are also with Charlemagne. And you have the sense there that Charlemagne has become the arbiter of both the Roman Emperor and of the Pope. You know, these two intimidating figures who had always viewed the King of the Franks as an absolute parvenu and he greets them in this kind of fresh, rough-hewn fortress called Paderborn, which had been built back in the 770s as a base for prosecuting the Saxon Wars, but which Charlemagne just the year before had founded as a bishopric. So you can see him presenting himself to the leaders of the ancient world as this vibrant go-ahead figure who is raising fortifications and churches in the wilds that had never been conquered by the ancient Romans. It's very, very impressive. Marcus of his prowess as a warlord, therefore, are very much being pushed in
好的。那么最大的问题，我们在本集开头提出的问题是：查理曼知道会发生什么吗？还是说艾因哈德说这是一次完全的意外时是对的？我不知道你怎么想，多米尼克，但我的意思是，这太明显了。我的意思是，他去过图尔，他专门和他的儿子们在那里祈祷过。他去过拉韦纳，那是——太明显了。我的意思是，他去过图尔。他专门和他的儿子们在那里祈祷过。他去过拉韦纳，那是前帝国首都。他在罗马城外遇到了教皇。他们带着庞大的随从队伍、以极高的荣誉进入了城内，诸如此类。
the noses of both the Byzantine ambassadors and of the Pope himself. Now, what the Pope and Charlemagne discuss, we don't know. We don't have a record of it, but he still very much got his finger on the pulse of geopolitics. And he writes a letter to Charles before the arrival of both the papal and Byzantine ambassadors. And in it, he points out how extraordinary what is happening actually is. Because as he says, there are three great figures of authority whom God has appointed to rule the world. And these are the Pope, the Emperor in the second Rome, so Constantinople, and Charlemagne himself. And he says, you know, the Pope is caught up in a scandal. The Emperor in Constantinople is a woman. This imposes on you a massive duty to God to do what is right for the Christian people. And he says, Alcon says this specifically, the Christian people depend upon the excellence of your power, the luster of your wisdom and
他为教皇准备了法律辩护，这样教皇就不会因通奸和入室盗窃而受审。拜托。我的意思是，这显而易见，这全部都是一项蓄谋已久且极其精心策划的计划的一部分。我的意思是，这就是纯粹的强权政治，不是吗？他进入罗马，他期待着等价交换。我的意思是，这是纯粹的强权政治，但这也是纯粹的强权政治与……
the loftiness of your dignity as a ruler. Behold, upon you alone rests the entire health deteriorated as it is of the churches of Christ. And it's hard to imagine that the implications of that letter are not very much on Charlemagne's mind as he consults with the Pope at Paderborn. No pressure, but he's got a great opportunity here, right? Because basically the other two authority figures are tarnished. There's question marks, shall we say, hanging over them. The question mark, of course, a Carolingian innovation. So Charlemagne has an opportunity here to really assert himself as Primus Inter Pares, right? The most important of all of these characters. Yes. So two or three years pass and we are now in the summer of AD 800. So the turning
我认为，查理曼有一种他在履行上帝旨意的意识，即这就是上帝希望他做的事，因为他已经安排好了国家事务，使之成为显而易见的选择。我想，我们可以从某种整体性的叙事中大致了解查理曼的想法——也就是逐年记录的叙事，这是最接近实际事件（即真正的加冕礼）的记录。这份关于加冕礼的记录明确指出，教皇将帝国称号授予查理曼有两个原因。其中第一个原因是，在希腊人的土地上，没有人拥有皇帝的称号。因此，伊琳娜不具备资格。君士坦丁堡的皇位是空缺的。但它补充说，查理曼理应获得这个称号，因为他是罗马的主人，而罗马在古代曾是恺撒的宝座，
of the century. And that summer, I think it's really telling. Charlemagne decides to head westwards to Tours, where of course Alcuin is abbot. He holds a summit there with his sons. So, he's consulting with his great teacher and advisor. He's consulting with his sons. And of course, he has the opportunity to pray the shrine of St. Martin, the most significant of all the patron saints of the Franks. He then heads for Paris, which had been the capital of Clovis, the Frankish king who had first converted to Christianity. Interestingly, Notre Dame has just opened as we're recording this episode. In front of Notre Dame, there's a great equestrian statue of Charlemagne. I think he's brandishing a sword. But this is the only visit that Charlemagne makes to the ancient capital of the Franks. But again, you're thinking, is he going to places that are significant in the history of
而且他也使自己成为了意大利、高卢和日耳曼的统治者，就像当年的恺撒一样。因此，显然凭借功绩，他被上帝选中，在罗马接过了恺撒的衣钵。这篇编年史确实接着说道：查理国王不愿拒绝教皇的请求。因此，在同年主的降生之日，他怀着所有的谦逊，在主教皇的祝福下接受了皇帝的称号——这必定是你所认为的那种感觉，你知道，正是那种他表现出谦逊和不愿接受的姿态。当然。
Franks because he's gearing himself up for a spectacular innovation? He wants reassurance that he's got God and kind of Frankish history on his side. Anyway, be that as it may, autumn is now starting to close in. And so he heads southwards and he makes for Ravenna, again, a very historically significant city. Yeah, of course. You know, it had been the seat of the last Roman emperors of the West. It's where the Byzantine governor of Italy had been at his capital. So again, kind of a place saturated in Western ideals of Roman imperialism. And then he goes across the Apennines and he approaches Rome and he's met on the 23rd of November, 799 by Pope Leo, about 15 miles outside Rome.
你知道，但是。是的，这本身就是一个古老的罗马把戏，对吧？还记得奥古斯都以及几个世纪前当他在元老院被授予无数头衔时所表现出的谦逊和礼让吗。所以从这个意义上说，你可以争辩说他的行为完全像一个皇帝应该有的样子。我认为你绝对可以这么争辩。而且我认为你也可以从这个时刻所倾注的心思和关切中看出这一点：尽管他在加冕时受到罗马人民的欢呼，被尊为罗马人的皇帝，但这并不是查理曼本人
He's entertained, we're told by chronicler, with great honor. And then the following day he makes a splendid entry into Rome. We're not told how many people he's got with him, but no doubt it's a very impressive and intimidating escort. So Charlemagne is now in Rome. There's a month to go before Christmas day. And the most pressing issue in front of both Charlemagne and the Pope is what to do about the charges that have been levelled against Leo. Fortunately for Leo and indeed probably for Charlemagne, Alcuin has prepared a legal case arguing that popes can't be tried and so therefore the charges of adultery and perjury that Leo's rivals had brought against him are basically swept under the carpet. Brilliant, all is good as new, Leo is ready to go. And so this is the background
一直使用的称号。其原因在于，他知道如果在君士坦丁堡跨越那条红线，如果他那样做了，他们将永远无法接受他，因为君士坦丁堡的皇帝一直自称为罗马人的皇帝。查理曼篡夺这个称号基本上就是宣战。因此，查理曼与阿尔琴（或者谁知道呢？显然经过了大量的深思熟虑）提出了一个不同的短语，即他是统治罗马帝国的皇帝。你知道，这显然是一种需要最高层讨论的表述。你知道，这就像今天人们在布鲁塞尔争论欧盟法律时那样，需要最高层讨论。这就像今天人们在布鲁塞尔争论欧盟法律时那样，
to the coronation on Christmas day 800. Right. And so the big question, you know, that we framed at the beginning of this episode is did Charlemagne know what was going to happen? Or is Einhard right when he says that it came as a complete surprise? And I don't know what you think Dominic, but I mean, pretty obvious. I mean, he's been to tour, he's specially prayed there with his sons. He's been to Ravenna, which is the, pretty obvious. I mean, he's been to tour. He's specially prayed there with his sons. He's been to Ravenna, which is the former imperial capital. He's met the Pope outside Rome. They've gone in with a huge escort with all great honor and all this kind of thing.
对此会无所不知。这正是那种层级的表述。因此我认为，多米尼克你也可能会同意，很显然，查理曼并没有被教皇打个措手不及，而是他识别出了自己的机会并抓住了它。其结果是：一个令人惊叹的节日发展。自公元476年以来，西方首次有了皇帝。
He's prepared a legal case for the Pope so the Pope can't be tried for adultery and burglary. Come on. I mean, it's blindingly obvious that this is all part of a long planned and very elaborate scheme. I mean, this is pure power politics, isn't it? He goes into Rome and he is expecting the quid pro quo. I mean, it is pure power politics, but it's pure power politics intermingled with,
扣人心弦的场景。休息过后，我们回来了解查理曼接下来发生了什么，我们还将讨论他在历史上的地位。他配得上“欧洲之父”的称号吗？事实上，法兰克人后来怎么样了？我们也会讨论这个问题。休息后见。本期节目由米勒淡啤（Miller Lite）赞助播出。米勒淡啤致力于庆祝友谊，尤其是在美式橄榄球梦幻联赛赛季期间。没有什么比米勒淡啤的“最后一名阵地”（Last Placements）更好的方式，向你的朋友兼梦幻联赛倒数第一名表达你“深沉的爱”了——在这里，你可以把他们的脸印在巨型广告牌上。没错，一个真正的广告牌。
I think, Charlemagne's sense that he is fulfilling God's purpose, that this is what God wants him to do because he has arranged the affairs of the nation to make it the obvious thing to do. And I think we have a sense of what Charlemagne was thinking from a kind of an holistic account, so a kind of year by year account that is the nearest to the actual event, so the actual coronation. And this account of the coronation specifically says that the Pope offers the imperial to Charlemagne for two reasons. And the first of these is in the land of the Greeks, there was no one who held the name of emperor. So, Irene doesn't qualify. The imperial throne in Constantinople is vacant. But it adds that Charlemagne deserves a title because he's
只需访问 lastplacements.com 了解如何参与。米勒淡啤，品味米勒时刻（Miller time）。节日来临了。准备好散发一些光彩了吗？这个季节，送出写着“我爱你”的礼物，来自佩普勒珠宝（People's Jewelers）。他们拥有让您所爱之人闪耀的款式，从永恒的钻石和宝石到耀眼黄金。这是向他们表达他们对您有多么重要的大好方式。
the master of Rome, which in ancient times had been the seat of the Caesars, and that also he has made himself the ruler of Italy, of Gaul, and of Germany as the Caesars had been. And therefore, clearly by merit, he has been chosen by God to take up the mantle of the Caesars in Rome. And this chronicle does go on to say King Charles was reluctant to deny the Pope's request. And so in all humility on that same day, the nativity of the Lord Jesus Christ, he received the name of emperor with the blessing of the Lord Pope and it must be that use, you know, it's that sense that he does it with a show of modesty and reluctance. Of course.
立即在佩普勒（People's）选购，今天就找到那件特别的饰品。让我们庆祝爱、友谊以及这个节日带来的所有欢乐。为爱而活，佩普勒珠宝。冬天到了，你可以通过 Uber Eats 配送获得你需要的一切。嗯，几乎，几乎一切。所以不，你无法在 Uber Eats 上买到雪球。但肉丸、马苏里拉奶酪球和意式炸饭团（arancini balls）？是的，我们配送这些。
You know, but. Yeah, which is an old Roman trick in itself, right? Remember Augustus and the show of modesty and humility that Augustus made when he was festooned with titles by the Senate centuries earlier. So in that sense, he's behaving exactly as an emperor should, you could argue. I think you absolutely could argue that. And I think you can also see the care and thought that has gone into this moment from the fact that even though he is hailed by the people of Rome when he's crowned as emperor of the Romans, this is not a title that Charlemagne himself
驼鹿？不。但驼鹿头啤酒（Moosehead）？是的。因为那是酒精，我们也配送这个。皇帝身体强壮，体格魁梧。他身材高大，但并不算过度，因为他的身高刚好是他自己脚长的七倍。他的头顶是圆的，眼睛锐利而且异常大。他的鼻子比正常情况稍长一点，他有着一头漂亮的白发，他的表情总是带着 amused（趣味）和幽默感。因此，无论他是坐着还是站着，他总是显得
ever uses. The reason for that is that he knows that he'd be crossing a red line there in Constantinople, that they would never be able to accept him if he did that because the Emperor in Constantinople has always called himself Emperor of the Romans. For Charlemagne to usurp that would essentially be a declaration of war. And so instead Charlemagne has come up with Alcmin, I mean, who knows? I mean, there's clearly a lot of thought gone into it with a different phrase, which is that he is the emperor governing the Roman Empire. You know, this is clearly the kind of formulation that requires a lot of top level discussion. You know, it's the kind of thing that today people in, you know, debating EU law in Brussels would be top level discussion. It's the kind of thing that today people
威严而有尊严。他的脖子又短又粗。他喜欢温泉蒸浴，只要有机会就喜欢在水中锻炼。他是一个极其强壮的游泳健将，在这项运动中没有人能超越他。正因如此，他在亚琛（Aachen）建造了他的宫殿，并在他生命的最后几年，一直持续居住在那里，事实上直到他去世的那一刻。他不仅会邀请他的儿子们和他一起洗澡，
debating EU law in Brussels would be all over it. It's that kind of order of formulation. So I think, and Dominic, you probably agree, it's pretty clear that Charlemagne is not taken by surprise by the pope, but that he had recognized his opportunity and seized it. And the result of this, an astonishing festive development. For the first time since AD 476, there is an emperor in the West.
在布鲁塞尔辩论欧盟法律的人会对它了如指掌。这就是那种表述方式。所以我认为，多米尼克，你可能也会同意，很明显，查理曼大帝并不是被教皇打了个措手不及，而是他认准了时机并抓住了它。而这一切的结果，是一次惊人的节日盛况。自公元476年以来，西方首次出现了皇帝。
Thrilling scenes. Come back after the break to find out what happens next to Charlemagne and we will be discussing his place in history. Does he deserve the title Father of Europe? And actually, what happened to the Franks? We'll discuss that too. Come back after the break. This episode is brought to you by Miller Lite. Miller Lite is all about celebrating friendships, especially during fantasy football season. And there's no better way to show your friends slash fantasy league's last place finisher that you love them than Miller Lite's Last Placements, where you can get their face on a billboard. Yep, a real billboard.
激动人心的场景。休息回来后，我们将继续探究查理曼大帝接下来发生了什么，并讨论他在历史上的地位。他配得上“欧洲之父”的称号吗？事实上，法兰克人后来怎么样了？我们也会讨论这个问题。休息一下，马上回来。本期节目由 Miller Lite 赞助播出。Miller Lite 致力于庆祝友谊，尤其是在梦幻橄榄球赛季期间。没有什么比 Miller Lite 的“终极倒数安置计划”更能向你的朋友兼梦幻联赛倒数第一名表达你的爱了，你可以把他们的脸印在广告牌上。没错，一个真正的广告牌。
Just go to lastplacements.com to find out how. Miller Lite tastes like Miller time. The holidays are here. Ready to spread some sparkle? This season, give the gift that says, I love you, from People's Jewelers. They have styles to make your loved ones shine, from timeless diamonds and gemstones to stunning gold. It's the perfect way to show just how much they mean to you.
只需访问 lastplacements.com 了解如何参与。Miller Lite 的滋味就像是美妙的时刻。假期到了。准备好散发一些光彩了吗？这个季节，送上一份代表“我爱你”的礼物，来自 People's Jewelers。他们拥有让你的挚爱闪耀的款式，从永恒的钻石、宝石到迷人的黄金。这是表达他们对你多么重要的完美方式。
Shop now at People's and find that special piece today. Let's celebrate love, friendship, and all the joy this holiday brings. Live for love with People's Jewelers. It's winter and you can get anything you need delivered with Uber Eats. Well, almost, almost anything. So no, you can't get snowballs on Uber Eats. But meatballs, mozzarella balls, and arancini balls? Yes, we deliver those.
立即在 People's 选购，今天就找到那件特别的饰品。让我们庆祝爱、友谊以及这个节日带来的所有欢乐。用 People's Jewelers 为爱而活。冬天到了，你可以通过 Uber Eats 配送任何你需要的东西。嗯，差不多，几乎所有东西。所以，不行，你无法在 Uber Eats 上买到雪球。但是肉丸、马苏里拉奶酪球和意式饭团？是的，我们配送这些。
Moose? No. But moose head? Yes. Because that's alcohol and we deliver that too. The Emperor was strong and well-built. He was tall in stature, but not excessively so, for his height was just seven times the length of his own feet. The top of his head was round, and his eyes were piercing and unusually large. His nose was slightly longer than normal, he had a fine head of white hair, and his expression was amused and good-humoured. As a result, whether he was seated or standing, he always appeared
驼鹿？不行。但驼鹿头？可以。因为那是酒精饮品，我们也配送。这位皇帝身材健美、体格强壮。他身材高大，但并不夸张，因为他的身高刚好是他自己脚长的七倍。他的头顶是圆的，眼神锐利且异常巨大。他的鼻子比正常情况稍长，他有一头漂亮的白发，他的表情总是带着 amused 和幽默。因此，无论他是坐着还是站着，他总是显得
masterful and dignified. His neck was short and rather thick. He took delight in steam baths at the thermal springs and loved to exercise in the water whenever he could. He was an extremely strong swimmer, and in this sport, no one could surpass him. It was for this reason that he built his palace at Aachen and remained continuously in residence there during the last years of his life, and indeed until the moment of his death. He would invite not only his sons to bathe with him,
威严庄重。他的脖子又短又粗。他喜欢在温泉里洗蒸汽浴，只要有可能，他都喜欢在水中锻炼。他是一位极其出色的游泳健将，在这项运动中，没有人能超越他。正因如此，他在亚琛建造了宫殿，并在他生命的最后几年里，一直住在那里，直到他去世的那一刻。他不仅会邀请他的儿子们和他一起洗澡，
but his nobles and friends as well, and occasionally even a crowd of his attendants and bodyguards, so that sometimes a hundred men or more would be in the water together. So that was Einhart, the fine head of white hair, his height seven times the length of his feet, his strange enthusiasm for mass swimming. Do you think these things are all true or are these the kind of formulaic details that you get in the lives of emperors? Well, so some of it must be true. I mean, Einhard knew Charlemagne and in the last years of his life was close to him, was very proud of it. Clearly aspects of it are true. The whole, you know, hanging out in baths with Alcuin and his crew and all that kind of stuff. I mean, that does seem to be true. And there is evidence for quite a lot of what Alcuin is describing of his personality, actually
还有他的贵族和朋友们，偶尔甚至还有一群随从和贴身保镖，有时会有上百人甚至更多人一起在水里。所以这就是埃因哈德笔下的查理曼：一头漂亮的白发，身高相当于七个脚掌长，对集体游泳有着奇异的热情。你觉得这些都是真的，还是只是帝王传记里那种套路化的细节呢？嗯，其中肯定有一部分是真的。我的意思是，埃因哈德认识查理曼，在他生命的最后几年一直陪伴在他身边，并对此感到非常自豪。显然，其中某些方面是真的。比如在浴池里和阿尔昆及其同伴们闲逛之类的事情。我的意思是，这似乎是真的。而且实际上有很多证据可以证明阿尔昆对查理曼性格的描述，
in anecdotes that are told about him and on occasion, I think in his own kind of distorted words. So his sense of humour, for instance, which occasionally, you know, you kind of get senses of it. Although as Ginny Nossin in her biography of him describes his jokes, actually not as being particularly good humour, but as hinged on humiliation and cruelty. So perhaps he wasn't quite as jolly as Einhard is making him out to be. But equally, you're right that we can't really be sure which aspects of this description are completely drawn from life and which are drawn from Suetonius, the biography of the Caesars, who provides Einhard with his great model.
体现在关于他的趣闻轶事中，有时我甚至认为体现在他自己那种扭曲的话语中。比如他的幽默感，偶尔你也能体会到那种感觉。尽管吉妮·诺辛在查理曼传记中对他的笑话的描述，实际上并不觉得它们特别幽默，而是建立在羞辱和残酷的基础上的。所以也许他并没有埃因哈德描绘得那么快活。但同样，你说得对，我们其实无法确定这些描述中究竟哪些完全取自现实，哪些取为苏埃托尼乌斯《恺撒传》的模板，后者为埃因哈德提供了伟大的创作范本。
But certainly the physical descriptions, there's a problem because almost all of them are drawn pretty much word for word from descriptions of the Caesars in Suetonius' biographies. So whether he's chosen phrases from Suetonius that map onto Charlemagne, we don't know, or whether he's just kind of constructing a portrait of the king from various fragments. Like a Frankenstein's monster. He's basically chosen the best bit of each emperor and bolted them all together. Yes, and this is a kind of process that you see elsewhere in Charlemagne's empire, not least in the palace that Einhard mentions in that description, the one with the baths at Aachen, which is still there. It's a wonderful place to
但可以肯定的是，外貌描写存在一个问题，因为几乎所有描写几乎都是逐字逐句摘自苏埃托尼乌斯传记中对恺撒的描述。所以，他究竟是挑选了苏埃托尼乌斯中与查理曼契合的短语，我们不得而知，还是他只是从各种碎片中拼凑出了国王的画像。就像弗兰肯斯坦的怪物一样。他基本上挑出了每位皇帝最好的部分，然后把它们全部拼凑在一起。是的，这种创作过程你在查理曼帝国的其他地方也能看到，尤其是埃因哈德在描述中提到的那座宫殿，也就是亚琛的那座带有浴场的宫殿，它至今仍在使用。那是一个非常棒的
visit. Have you been to Aachen, Dominic? I've never been to Aachen. Is it nice? Yeah, it is. And it's kind of right on the western-based border of Germany, basically Belgium, the Netherlands. It's where they all kind of join up. So the heart of Europe, you might say. And certainly it was in the heart of Austrasia, which was the ancient Frankish sub-kingdom that was the Carolingian heartland. So that's one of the reasons why Charlemagne chooses it. But the other reason is I think that he begins it in 791 when the war against the Avars and the Saxons are really kicking off. And I think he, you know, he wants it to be readily accessible with the Eastern front.
参观地点。多米尼克，你去过亚琛吗？我从来没去过亚琛。那里好玩吗？是的，挺不错的。它基本上位于德国西部的边境，挨着比利时和荷兰。可以说是它们交汇的地方。所以，你也可以说它是欧洲的中心。而且它无疑是奥斯特拉西亚的中心，奥斯特拉西亚是加洛林王朝发源地的古代法兰克王国子王国。这也是查理曼选择这里的原因之一。但另一个原因我认为是，他在791年开始建造它，当时对阿瓦尔人和萨克森人的战争正打得如火如荼。我想他，你知道的，他希望这个地方紧邻东线，便于出入。
And in fact, all the loot that gets taken from the Avars, so in the previous episode, we described Ironheart watching it, you know, the wagonsons rumbling in piled high with jewels and all kinds of stuff. Essentially, it's this loot that enables Charlemagne to build Arkham. He can employ the very best. He's got all this sudden windfall. And a bit like Einhard cannibalizing Suetonius for descriptions of Charlemagne. This palace, which also includes a great church, it too consists of various fragments of architectural salvage. So the bath house had originally been a Roman one. It gets repaired and installed into the palace. The layout of the roads in the palace, they too are Roman. Charlemagne wants for his palace and for his church authentically
事实上，从阿瓦尔人那里掠夺来的所有战利品——所以在上一集中，我们描述了铁心（Ironheart）看着它们，你知道的，一辆辆满载着珠宝和各种物品的马车隆隆驶入。从根本上说，正是这些战利品让查理曼得以建造亚琛。他能够雇佣最顶尖的人才，他突然得到了这么一大笔意外之财。就像埃因哈德为了描写查理曼而取材于苏埃托尼乌斯一样。这座宫殿还包括一座宏大的教堂，它同样由各种建筑残片拼凑而成。比如浴室原本是一座罗马浴室。它被修复并安装进了宫殿。宫殿里道路的布局也是罗马风格的。查理曼希望为他的宫殿和教堂配备地道的
Roman pillars. So he has them brought to him from Roman Ravenna, where of course you have imperial standard architecture waiting to be plundered. So there is a sense in which it is a kind of Frankenstein's monster building. But when you go there, I don't think you feel that it is Ersatz. I don't think that you feel that it's a pastiche. Certainly you don't get any sense of this at all from contemporary chroniclers. Visitors to this complex marvel at it and they are impressed and they are intimidated by the sense it gives them of just how great a king Charlemagne is. So again to quote Nelson, arc and emanated power through its design and architectural style, through
罗马柱。于是他让人把它们从罗马拉文纳运来，那里当然有可供掠夺的帝国标准建筑。从某种意义上说，它确实是一座弗兰肯斯坦式的建筑。但当你去到那里时，我认为你不会觉得它是山寨货。我不认为你会觉得它是一种矫揉造作的仿制品。当然，当时的编年史家们根本没有这种感觉。来到这个建筑群的游客对它赞叹不已，他们被它所传达出的查理曼究竟是多么伟大的国王这种感觉所震撼和折服。所以还是引用纳尔逊的话，亚琛通过其设计和建筑风格、通过
gardens, parks and forests, through relics and altars, through ceremonial entries and through rituals whereby rulers were made. So I think it is impressive. So it's exactly as they think it should be. They think a palace, an emperor, should be the sum of their Roman predecessors, right? They perhaps wouldn't have the concept of it being a pastiche. They think it's exactly as it should be. When you read books of general history about this period, it will often be sneered at. Historians will say, oh, you know, it's laughable, it's contemptible. And obviously this comes with the perspective of how impressive and imposing and cosmopolitan
花园、公园和森林、通过圣物和圣坛、通过盛大的入城仪式以及通过塑造统治者的仪式散发着权力。所以我认为它令人印象深刻。所以它完全符合他们心中的预期。他们认为宫殿、皇帝就应该是他们罗马前任的集大成者，对吧？他们可能没有将其视为仿制品的概念。他们认为它本来就该是这个样子。当你阅读关于这段时期的通史书籍时，它经常受到嘲讽。历史学家会说，哦，你知道，这简直荒谬可笑，令人不齿。这显然是带着一种宏大视角来看待的，即帝国是多么令人印象深刻、雄伟壮观且具有大都会气息。
Constantinople is. Baghdad, Cordova, the great capital of Byzantium and the two great capitals of the rival caliphates, the Abbasid caliphate based in Baghdad and the Ameyad caliphate based in Cordova. And Aachen can't compare to that. And Baghdad especially, it's the center of the world. It's not just the great cultural center, it's the great trading center. And so it's rich beyond the wildest imagining of the Franks. And this is why both in Einhard and in other chronicles, they are particularly impressed by embassies that get sent to Charlemagne by the caliph in Baghdad, Harun al-Rashid, so the famous caliph from the Arabian Nights. And there are two
君士坦丁堡。巴格达、科尔多瓦，拜占庭的伟大首都以及两个敌对哈里发国的两大首都，即以巴格达为基地的阿拔斯哈里发国和以科尔多瓦为基地的倭马亚哈里发国。而亚琛根本无法与之相比。特别是巴格达，它是世界的中心。它不仅是伟大的文化中心，也是伟大的贸易中心。所以它的财富超出了法兰克人最疯狂的想象。这就是为什么无论是在埃因哈德还是在其他编年史中，他们都对巴格达哈里发哈伦·拉希德（即《一千零一夜》中的著名哈里发）派往查理曼的使团印象尤为深刻。而且有两个
embassies in particular, which the Franks are really wowed by. The first one comes in 802, so that's two years after Charlemagne's coronation. And Harun sends him an elephant, which is given the name Abul Abbas, and he arrives in Aachen in 802 and is a great favourite and Charlemagne is very, very keen on him. In 807, again, an embassy comes and it's full of amazing treasures. And this kind of very touching account from Einhard, he'd obviously seen it of a clock, which it's clearly nothing like he's ever seen before. And he describes it in enormous detail, a brass clock constructed with marvelous mechanical skill in which the passage of the 12 hours
特别让法兰克人惊叹的使团。第一个使团在802年到达，也就是查理曼加冕两年后。哈伦送给他一头大象，名字叫阿布·阿巴斯，它于802年抵达亚琛，非常受欢迎，查理曼对它喜爱有加。807年，又有一个使团到来，里面装满了惊人的宝藏。埃因哈德对此有一种非常感人的描述，他显然亲眼见过一个时钟，这显然是他见所未见的。他极其详尽地描述了它，这是一个用精湛的机械技艺制造的黄铜时钟，其中12个小时的流逝
depended upon a water clock with 12 little copper balls and 12 horsemen, one of which would emerge from one of 12 windows. It's easy to imagine that these gifts are being sent by Harun to intimidate Charlemagne, to patronise him as a kind of an expression of condescension. But I don't think that's right. I think they are sent as genuine markers of respect, both because Harun can respect an emperor who's been crowned in Rome. The fame of Rome still endures in the lands of Islam, and that is quite something to be an emperor crowned in Rome, even in Baghdad. quite something to be an emperor crowned in Rome, even in Baghdad. It's also because Harun needs Charlemagne because Harun as the Abbasid Caliphate has a rival in the form of the Ameyad Caliph who's emerged in Spain, in Muslim Spain. And the Ameyad Caliph is their common enemy.
依靠一个水钟，带有12个小铜球和12个骑马人，其中一个会从12个窗户之一中钻出来。人们很容易认为这些礼物是哈伦为了恐吓查理曼、以一种居高临下的优越感来恩赐他而送来的。但我认为并非如此。我认为它们是作为真诚的敬意标志送出的，一方面是因为哈伦尊重一位在罗马加冕的皇帝。罗马的声誉在伊斯兰土地上依然长存，在罗马加冕为皇帝可不是件小事，即使在巴格达也是如此。在罗马加冕为皇帝可不是件小事，即使在巴格达也是如此。这也是因为哈伦需要查理曼，因为作为阿拔斯哈里发国的哈伦，在西班牙（穆斯林西班牙）崛起了一个对手——倭马亚哈里发。而倭马亚哈里发是他们共同的敌人。
And the fact that Harun is a Muslim and Charlemagne is Christian, that's less significant than the fact that both of them have an interest in allying with one another against the common foe. And in fact, shortly after the arrival of the elephant in Aachen, Charlemagne shows that this investment has been worth Charlemagne's while because he starts a war beyond the Pyrenees, which he'd left alone since the disaster at Rontes Vvalles. And in 804 Charlemagne's son Louis captures the great city of Barcelona and this will remain in Christian hands from now on. So that's good news for Charlemagne. Weirdly, it's also good for Rune. And I think in a similar way, even in Constantinople, I think there's a sense that Charlemagne probably deserves the imperial title. And so in 812, there's been a long delay over a decade, but in 812,
事实上，哈伦是穆斯林，查理曼是基督徒，这一点的重要性不如两人为了共同的敌人而结盟的共同利益。事实上，大象抵达亚琛后不久，查理曼就证明了这笔投资对查理曼来说是值得的，因为他在比利牛斯山脉以南发动了一场战争，自龙塞斯瓦列斯灾难以来，他一直没有管过那里。804年，查理曼的儿子路易攻克了伟大的城市巴塞罗那，此后这座城市一直掌握在基督徒手中。这对查理曼来说是个好消息。说来也怪，对哈伦来说也很好。我认为以类似的方式，甚至在君士坦丁堡，我也觉得有一种看法认为查理曼可能配得上皇帝的称号。因此在812年，经过了长时间的拖延——超过十年，但在812年，
Byzantine ambassadors do come to Arkan and they bring acknowledgement of Charlemagne's rank. And the compromise is one that Charlemagne had prepared for, that the emperor in Constantinople will be the emperor of the Romans. Charlemagne is just emperor. Both sides are content with that. So it's almost like he's not exactly a subordinate emperor, is he? But he's perhaps just a kind of in prestige, just a notch down, because the emperor in Constantinople is the more obvious heir to the legacy of Rome. But they're acknowledging that Charlemagne kind of has a claim, I suppose. Is that right? I think it's even more than that. I think it's the fact that the Byzantines at this
拜占庭使节确实来到了亚琛，他们带来了对查理曼地位的承认。双方达成的妥协是查理曼早已准备好的，即君士坦丁堡的皇帝将成为罗马人的皇帝。查理曼则只是皇帝。双方对此都很满意。所以这几乎就像是他并不是一个下属皇帝，对吧？但他在声望上可能只是低了一个档次，因为君士坦丁堡的皇帝才是罗马遗产更名正言顺的继承人。但他们承认查理曼某种程度上拥有这一主张，我想是这样的吧？我认为还不止于此。我认为事实是拜占庭人在此时
point, their empire is very ragged. They've been fighting for survival for almost a century at this point. Whereas the empire of the Franks is incredibly intimidating and impressive. So I think this is Charlemagne's great political achievement that he is the first ruler in what had been the Western half of the Roman Empire to be acknowledged in Constantinople and also in Baghdad as an heir to Roman rule. Of course, neither the emperor in Constantinople nor the caliph in Baghdad prepared to acknowledge him as an equal. I mean, neither of them would do that. But the fact that they're sending him ambassadors and elephants and clocks and all this, I mean, it's an acknowledgement that he has arrived,
他们的帝国已经非常破败了。此时他们为了生存已经战斗了近一个世纪。而法兰克人的帝国却极其令人畏惧和震撼。所以我认为这是查理曼伟大的政治成就，他成为了原罗马帝国西部地区第一位在君士坦丁堡和巴格达都被承认的罗马统治者继承人。当然，无论是君士坦丁堡的皇帝还是巴格达的哈里发，都不准备承认他是平起平坐的。我的意思是，他们谁都不会这么做。但他们派来使者、大象、时钟和这一切，我的意思是，这是一种承认，承认他已经崛起，
that he is a worthy heir of Rome, which is what the Franks had always wanted to be. Charlemagne has finally kind of sealed the deal and they are responding to measurable kind of indices of greatness. So, you know, lands conquered, plunder taken from defeated enemies, diplomatic muscle exercised, military muscle exercised. But you are right equally, of course, that he does remain an upstart. He's a king who's had to make himself an emperor. He's got a palace that's built with all kinds of stuff nicked from other palaces. Bits of other people's palaces. Yeah. And the towns that he rules, even Rome, even Arkan, even Paris, even Tor, compared
承认他是罗马合格的继承人，而这正是法兰克人一直想成为的。查理曼终于尘埃落定，他们正在对伟大程度的可衡量指标做出回应。所以，你看，征服的土地，从被打败的敌人那里夺取的战利品，施展的外交手腕，施展的军事实力。但同样，当然，他也确实是一个暴发户。他是一个不得不把自己变成皇帝的国王。他的宫殿里建满了从其他宫殿顺来的各种东西。别人的宫殿的碎片。是的。还有他统治的城镇，即使是罗马，即使是亚琛，即使是巴黎，即使是图尔，相比之下
to Constantinople or Baghdad, these are just tiny primprinks. They're kind of nothing. And so there's this disconcerting sense when you look at Charlemagne and his empire, that his achievements seem simultaneously imposingly solid. This is a figure like a Roman emperor making the earth shake beneath his tread. And yet at the same time, it seems weirdly insubstantial, like a kind of phantasmagoria that might just melt on the mist. Right. Because so much of it is based on his own personal charisma, prestige, a military nous, rather than institutional underpinnings that might be there in Constantinople or Baghdad. I think that's the key fact. There
与君士坦丁堡或巴格达相比，这些只是微不足道的小地方。它们什么都不是。因此，当你审视查理曼和他的帝国时，有一种令人不安的感觉，他的成就似乎既有令人印象深刻的坚实感。这是一个像罗马皇帝一样让大地在他脚下颤抖的人物。然而与此同时，它又显得离奇地不具实体，就像一个随时可能在迷雾中消融的幻影。没错。因为这其中很大一部分是建立在他个人的个人魅力、声望、军事谋略之上，而不是像君士坦丁堡或巴格达那样可能存在的体制基础。我认为这是关键事实。那里
isn't the kind of institutional muscle memory that you get in these empires that are drawing on very ancient traditions of imperialism. Charlemagne, he's kind of making it up as he goes along really. Well, I was going to ask about that because he doesn't presumably have the kind of bureaucracy. I mean, Constantinople is famous for its bureaucracy. Of course, the same thing is true of Baghdad. They have all kinds of civil service networks and long established, not decades, but centuries. He has his priests with their little kind of book of the Lord's Prayer and stuff that he's sent out.
没有那些从非常古老的帝国主义传统中汲取营养的帝国中所拥有的那种制度上的肌肉记忆。查理曼，他真的是在边走边摸索。嗯，我正要问这个，因为他大概没有那种官僚机构。我的意思是，君士坦丁堡以其官僚机构闻名。当然，巴格达也是如此。他们拥有各种各样的公务员网络，而且历史悠久，不是几十年，而是几个世纪。他有他的神父们，带着他们那种主祷文的小册子之类的东西，被他派了出去。
But in the West, presumably, there's nothing like the kind of really densely sophisticated financial bureaucratic networks that they have out in the East, which has always been so much richer. That's true. There is a kind of concentration of scholars and very, very literate and impressive people in Aachen. But there isn't, you're right, the concentration that you would get in Constantinople or Baghdad. But in a way, what you do have is a pointer to the future of medieval Europe. You have people who are scattered across the Frankish Empire and indeed in Britain as well in the monasteries there. And thanks to Charlemagne's long and very productive reign, these people are now joined by common culture in a way that had not previously been the case. And so this looks forward to the culture of the high and middle ages, when people in
但在西方，大概没有什么东西能比得上他们在东方拥有的那种真正密集、复杂的金融官僚网络，东方一直要富裕得多。确实如此。亚琛确实聚集了一批学者以及非常有文化、令人印象深刻的人。但你说的对，没有君士坦丁堡或巴格达那种集中度。但在某种程度上，你所拥有的确实是通往中世纪欧洲未来的风向标。你拥有散布在法兰克帝国以及英国修道院里的人们。由于查理曼漫长而成果丰硕的统治，这些人现在通过共同的文化联系在一起，而这在以前是没有过的。因此，这展望了高地和中世纪的文化，当时人们在
Scandinavia or in Spain or in Iceland or whatever will all feel that they're part of a common culture. And in that sense, we said in the previous episode, Charlemagne is the father of Europe. And this cadre of scholars, of administrators, of monks, they are impressive, I think. So just to quote Peter Brown in his book, The Rise of Western Christendom, all together with the scholar administrators of the Carolingian Empire, we're dealing with a singularly purposeful body of men. In their writings, many of them appear as the first technocrats of Europe. So it's no wonder that people in the EU are so keen on
斯堪的纳维亚、西班牙、冰岛或任何地方都会觉得自己是共同文化的一部分。从这个意义上说，正如我们在上一集里所说的那样，查理曼是欧洲之父。而这支由学者、行政人员、僧侣组成的精英骨干，我认为令人印象深刻。正如彼得·布朗在他的《西方基督教世界的兴起》一书中引用的那样，加洛林帝国的学者行政人员共同构成了一个目标极其明确的群体。在他们的著作中，许多人显得像是欧洲的第一批技术官僚。难怪欧盟的人对
Charlemagne. I mean, they're always kind of disputing prizes and stuff. In a sense, he has presided over the creation of a tradition that will endure long after his death through the Middle Ages, survive the Reformation, and in a sense is manifest to this day in the European Union. But of course, all of that is far in the future. The immediate question is what will happen after Charlemagne dies. And in the autumn of 813, so one year after his claim to the imperial title has been acknowledged by the Byzantines, he falls ill. He continues to go hunting and this just makes him worse. Late November, he retires to bed, stays there and he dies on the 28th of January, 814, at the ripe old age of 65. His body is wrapped by his daughters in a great shroud of gold and purple silk. It's been woven in
查理曼如此热衷。我的意思是，他们总是为了奖项之类的事情争论不休。从某种意义上说，他主持了一个传统的创造，这个传统将在他死后延续漫长的中世纪，历经宗教改革的洗礼，并在某种程度上一直延续到今天的欧洲联合体。但当然，所有这一切都在遥远的未来。当务之急是查理曼死后会发生什么。813年秋天，也就是他的皇帝头衔被拜占庭人承认的一年后，他病倒了。他继续去打猎，这使得他的病情更加恶化。11月下旬，他卧床不起，并于814年1月28日逝世，享年65岁高龄。他的女儿们用一块巨大的金紫丝绸织成的寿衣包裹了他的遗体。这块织物是在
Constantinople, illustrated with patterns showing charioteers. And he's then placed in an ancient Roman sarcophagus, probably decorated with scenes showing the rape of Proserpina by Pluto. He's then buried in his chapel at Arkan. He is succeeded by his son Louis, the guy who had captured Barcelona, both as King of the Franks and the Lombards and as emperor. Charlemagne had made really sure that Louis would inherit the title because the year before his death, he had had Louis crowned joint emperor the previous September. And it was Charlemagne who had done the crowning, not the Pope. And in fact, the Pope hadn't even been invited. And so there seems to be a deliberate policy on Charlemagne's
君士坦丁堡织造的，上面饰有描绘战车御者的图案。随后，他被安放在一个古罗马石棺中，上面可能装饰着冥王普鲁托劫持珀耳塞福涅的场景。接着他被安葬在亚琛的礼拜堂里。他的儿子路易（即攻克巴塞罗那的那个人）继承了他的法兰克人和伦巴第人国王以及皇帝的位子。查理曼确实确保了路易将继承这个头衔，因为在他去世前一年，他在前一年9月份让路易加冕为共治皇帝。而且是查理曼亲自主持的加冕典礼，而不是教皇。事实上，教皇甚至都没有被邀请。因此，这似乎是查理曼深思熟虑的政策，
part to exclude the Pope from the ritual of coronation. He wants to kind of hug it to his own dynasty. And then just for good measure, a month after Charlemagne's death, when Louis arrives in Aachen, he has himself crowned as emperor again. So, I mean, this is a considerable achievement. The empire is handed over intact to a son. And so listeners may be wondering, well, that's great, isn't it? Surely with such a fair wind, the empire of the Franks as constituted by Charlemagne, will endure for decades and centuries to come. Spoiler alert, it doesn't. So what goes wrong? Because Louis, King of the Franks, King of the Lombards, he's emperor, you know, he's got this massive military machine, his father has left him
旨在将教皇排除在加冕仪式之外。他想要把这一权力紧紧抓在自己的王朝手中。然后为了保险起见，在查理曼死后一个月，路易抵达亚琛，再次给自己加冕为皇帝。所以，我的意思是，这是一项相当大的成就。帝国完好无损地移交给了儿子。所以听众们可能在想，太棒了，不是吗？有了这样顺风顺水的基础，由查理曼建立的法兰克帝国肯定会延续几十甚至几百年吧。剧透一下，并没有。那么究竟哪里出错了呢？因为路易，法兰克人的国王，伦巴第人的国王，他是皇帝，你知道的，他拥有庞大的军事机器，他的父亲留给他了
the most incredible legacy. What on earth happens to this empire that Charlemagne is built and Louis is inherited? Why don't we know more? Why isn't it an empire to conjure with for the next kind of 300 years or something? Well, I think the issue is that Frankish kings, whether they're Merovingian or Carolingian, this is a trend that has been operating since the time of Clovis, cannot help themselves from dividing their kingdoms up between their sons and heirs. So although Louis has inherited Charlemagne's empire in its entirety, that had not originally been Charlemagne's intention. Charlemagne had three sons and he was planning
最不可思议的遗产。查理曼建立、路易继承的这个帝国到底发生了什么？为什么我们对它了解不多？为什么它在接下来的300年左右没有成为一个叱咤风云的帝国？嗯，我认为问题在于法兰克国王，无论是加洛林王朝还是墨洛温王朝——自克洛维时代以来就一直在运作的一种趋势——都无法克制自己不把王国分给儿子和继承人。因此，尽管路易完整地继承了查理曼的帝国，但这最初并不是查理曼的意图。查理曼有三个儿子，他曾计划
to divide the empire up between them. And two of those sons died before Charlemagne does. So that's why Louis is able to inherit it and also able to inherit the title of emperor, which initially Charlemagne had not seen as hereditary. He hadn't been planning to hand that on. So essentially, the fact that Louis inherits the empire intact and the imperial title is an accident. And Louis' problem is that like Charlemagne, he has three sons, but all of them survive him. And through his reign these sons are very badly behaved. They're endlessly causing civil wars, trying to grab chunks of the empire. And after Louis' death, they basically tear the Frankish Empire into pieces. So in 843, Louis' three sons meet up for one of the most politically significant meetings, conferences in the whole
把帝国在他们之间瓜分。其中两个儿子在查理曼去世前就夭折了。这就是为什么路易能够继承它，并且还能够继承皇帝的头衔，而查理曼最初并不认为这个头衔是世袭的。他本来没打算把它传下去。所以本质上，路易完整继承帝国和皇帝头衔纯属巧合。而路易的问题在于，和查理曼一样，他也有三个儿子，但他们都活了下来。在路易统治期间，这些儿子表现非常糟糕。他们没完没了地挑起内战，试图抢夺帝国的领土。路易死后，他们基本上把法兰克帝国撕成了碎片。所以在843年，路易的三个儿子会面，举行了具有重大政治意义的会议，
of European history. And they meet at Verdun, as in the Great First World War battle. Ironically, given what's going to happen. Yeah, very ironically, because what is negotiated at Verdun essentially will result in the permanent division of the Frankish Empire into three parts, because Louis' three surviving sons – Charles, Louis, again, so he'll rule as Louis II, and Lothar, a kind of ancient Merovingian name – they each take a massive chunk of the Frankish Empire. So Charles receives the western portion of Francia. This is the future kingdom of France. Louis receives the more German speaking lands to the east. So that includes Saxony, the Duchy of Franconia,
欧洲历史上的一场会议。他们在凡尔登会面，就像第一次世界大战中的那场大战一样。考虑到即将发生的事情，这具有讽刺意味。是的，非常具有讽刺意味，因为凡尔登谈判的内容实质上将导致法兰克帝国永久分裂为三部分——因为路易的三个幸存的儿子——查理、路易（再次登基，将作为路易二世统治）以及洛泰尔（一个古老的墨洛温名字）——他们每人都拿走了法兰克帝国的一大块土地。所以查理获得了法兰克尼亚的西部。这就是未来的法兰克王国。路易获得了东部更多说德语的土地。其中包括萨克森、法兰克尼亚公国，
a Frankish land that's been planted on the eastern banks of the Rhine. And this will be the future Germany. Lothar, who is the eldest son and who inherits the imperial title, he also inherits this kind of rackety inheritance, which is a whole tranche of disparate territories running from the low countries, so the future, the Netherlands and Belgium, down through Burgundy, across the Alps and including Italy. And what makes this inheritance even more rackety is that Lothar then has three sons of himself, and he divides his kingdom into three. Absolute madness. And the eldest of Lothar's sons,
一块位于莱茵河东岸的法兰克土地。这将是未来的德国。洛泰尔作为长子，不仅继承了皇帝的头衔，还继承了一份摇摇欲坠的遗产，这是一大片截然不同的领土，从低地国家（即未来的荷兰和比利时），经勃艮第，穿过阿尔卑斯山一直延伸到意大利。让这份遗产更加摇摇欲坠的是，洛泰尔自己又有三个儿子，他把自己的王国分成了三份。绝对是疯了。而洛泰尔的大儿子，
who again is called Louis, he gets the kingdom of Italy. That's his sole inheritance. And he gets the title of emperor. He hasn't really got any kind of launch pad for it. He doesn't have the muscle that an emperor properly should have. And because his geopolitical power is now so attenuated, getting kind of religious sanction becomes all the more important. And so this Louis, the emperor who rules only this chunk of Northern Italy, he goes back on the intentions of Charlemagne and he gets the pope involved again, because he needs the pope basically to burnish his credentials. So he goes to Rome and the pope crowns him.
同样名叫路易，他得到了意大利王国。那是他唯一的遗产。他也得到了皇帝的头衔。但他并没有真正为此打下任何基础。他没有一个皇帝应有的实力。由于他的地缘政治力量现在如此衰弱，获得宗教上的认可变得更加重要。因此，这位路易——这位仅统治这一小片意大利北部土地的皇帝——违背了查理曼的意愿，重新把教皇拉了进来，因为他基本上需要教皇来为自己的信誉镀金。于是他前往罗马，由教皇为他加冕。
This essentially establishes as a precedent for future emperors the fact that you can't really be an emperor unless the pope crowns you in Rome. So it's brilliant for the pope, but Louis, it doesn't really help him at all. And the measure of this is that in 871, he gets a very gloating letter from Constantinople, which openly jeers at his claim to be an emperor. Byzantines had respected Charlemagne, but they're not going to acknowledge that this guy who just rules a chunk of Italy, you know, he's an absolute loser. They're not going to allow him to be an emperor. And they say, you know, there is only the single empire, there is only the single emperor.
这基本上为未来的皇帝确立了一个先例，即除非教皇在罗马为你加冕，否则你根本算不上真正的皇帝。所以这对教皇来说太棒了，但对路易来说，这其实一点帮助也没有。这方面的证明是，在871年，他收到了一封来自君士坦丁堡的幸灾乐祸的信，信中公开嘲笑他自称为皇帝的权利。拜占庭人曾经尊重查理曼，但他们不会承认这个只统治一小块意大利土地的家伙，你知道的，他是个彻头彻尾的失败者。他们绝不会允许他成为皇帝。他们说，你知道的，只有一个单一的帝国，只有一个单一的皇帝。
The Franks have no claim to it. We do not respect your claim. Forget it. So Tom, the obvious question, which will have occurred to probably 99% of the listeners, the Franks destroy their own empire by dividing it up in this way. Why did they not simply pass on the empire to the oldest or the most proficient son, which is frankly, frankly, ironically, which is what kings and emperors all over the world have done for so long? Why do they persist with this? I mean, I suppose you could say, well, they do it because they want to avoid civil wars or whatever. But since the consequences
法兰克人对此没有任何权力声索。我们不尊重你的主张。算了吧。那么托姆，一个显而易见的问题，大约99%的听众都会想到：法兰克人通过这种瓜分方式毁掉了自己的帝国。为什么他们不干脆把帝国传给最年长或能力最强的儿子呢？坦白说，这具有讽刺意味的是，这正是世界各地的国王和皇帝长期以来一直在做的事情。为什么他们要坚持这种做法？我的意思是，你可能会说，嗯，他们这样做是为了避免内战之类的。但既然后果
are so baleful for their empire, why on earth do they persist with this ridiculous method of dividing it up? They do it because that's what Frankish kings do. And they're the heirs to the traditions of the Carolingian and then before them, the Merovingian monarchy. They do it because that's what their ancestors have always done. You might think, well, that's a kind of mad barbarian habit. Yeah. I mean, I do think that. People who've stuck with us throughout this entire series may remember that back in episode one, we said, which it kind of news to me when I looked into it, that this tradition was not a kind of
对他们的帝国来说是如此灾难性，为什么他们还要坚持这种荒谬的瓜分方法呢？他们这样做是因为法兰克国王历来如此。他们是加洛林王朝传统、以及在此之前的墨洛温王朝君主制传统的继承人。他们这样做是因为他们的祖先一直都是这么做的。你可能会想，嗯，这真是一种疯狂的野蛮习惯。是的。我的意思是，我的确这么认为。一路上陪伴我们走完全部系列的听众可能会记得，早在第一集我们就说过，当我深入了解时，这对我来说算是个新闻，这种传统并非某种
mad barbarian habit. It actually originated in the desire of Clovis to copy Roman practice, because it was the habit of the Roman Empire in its final centuries that it was too big and so it needed to be divided up into various parts. Yeah, of course. That's the kind of one of many ironies that shadow the final centuries of the Frankish Empire is that they kind of do destroy themselves, but they do it ultimately for Roman reasons. So ironic. So that is one reason I think why the Frankish Empire starts to disintegrate. The other however, is that the age when the Franks could go on the offensive comes to a stop and in fact, it is outsiders who start to prey on the Frankish Empire. And there are two
疯狂的野蛮习惯。它实际上源于克洛维效仿罗马做法的愿望，因为罗马帝国在其最后几个世纪的习惯是，帝国太大了，因此需要将其拆分为不同的部分。是的，当然。这是笼罩法兰克帝国最后几个世纪的众多讽刺之一，那就是他们确实自我毁灭了，但他们最终这样做的原因却是出于罗马式的理由。太讽刺了。所以这就是为什么法兰克帝国开始走向解体的原因之一。然而，另一个原因在于，法兰克人能够发起进攻的时代结束了，事实上，正是外来者开始掠夺法兰克帝国。其中有两个
bodies of raiders in particular who cause havoc all along the line of the Frankish dominion. So the first of these, the Arabs come back on the offensive. Their launch pad this time isn't Spain as it had been back in the age of Charles Martel, but North Africa and then after the conquest of Sicily, Southern Italy. And throughout the ninth century, the coastline of Italy is subjected to repeated raids. I mean, this is why today so many Italian cities on the coast, especially in southern Italy, are up on hills. There is no option but to retreat from the depredations of the Saracen pirates, as they're described. And in 846, it's the measure of what a menace they are. They actually sail up the Tiber,
特别是四处劫掠的团伙，在法兰克统治的整个战线沿途制造浩劫。其中第一个团伙是阿拉伯人卷土重来，发起进攻。这一次他们的出发点不是查理·马特时代那样的西班牙，而是北非，随后在征服西西里之后，来到了意大利南部。在整个9世纪期间，意大利海岸屡遭袭击。我的意思是，这就是为什么今天意大利有那么多沿海城市，尤其是意大利南部的城市，都建在山丘上。面对被描述为萨拉森海盗的掠夺，除了撤退别无他法。846年，他们的威胁程度达到了极点。他们甚至逆台伯河而上，
they can't break through the walls of Rome, but St Peter's and the Vatican is exposed, the cathedral is sacked, and a particularly humiliating emblem of how low Frankish power has fallen. A great silver table that Charlemagne had presented to St Peter is stolen by the pirates and carted off. So that's very bad. But even worse, of course, are old friends, the Vikings. And they had actually arrived on the scene back in the final years of Charlemagne's reign. So, 793 is the famous raid by the Vikings on the shrine of St Cuthbert on the island of Lindisfarne off Northumbria. And Alcuin, as a Northumbrian, he was in Frankia when the news came to him,
他们无法突破罗马的城墙，但圣彼得大教堂和梵蒂冈暴露了，大教堂遭到洗劫，这成为了法兰克权力堕落的一个特别屈辱的象征。查理曼赠给圣彼得大教堂的一张巨大的白银桌子被海盗盗走并运走了。这真是太糟糕了。但更糟糕的当然是老朋友维京人。他们实际上在查理曼统治的最后几年就已经登上了历史舞台。所以，793年是维京人对诺森布里亚海岸外林迪斯法恩岛上的圣库斯伯特圣地著名的袭击。作为诺森布里亚人，阿尔昆在消息传到他那里时正在法兰克，
was appalled. And he writes to the Bishop of Lindisfarne full of distress, kind of, you know, offering his sympathies and prayers. And by 808, the Danes are starting to launch raids on Saxony and Charlemagne actually in his final years is preparing to go to war against them. And in the end, the only reason he doesn't is that the Danish King Godefred is murdered by one of his own military guards. And so that puts off the Danish attack for a few years, but it's not long before the Vikings and the Danes are back. And I think there is a case for saying that one of the factors in the emergence of the Vikings may well have been the intrusion of the Franks directly onto the borders of Scandinavia that rather like Roman power abutting,
他感到震惊。他给林迪斯法恩的主教写了一封信，充满痛苦，某种程度上（你知道的）表达了他的同情和祈祷。到了808年，丹麦人开始对萨克森发动袭击，查理曼在生命的最后几年里实际上正准备对他们开战。最后，他之所以没有打起来，唯一的真正原因是因为丹麦国王戈德弗雷德被他自己的一个近卫军谋杀了。这把丹麦人的进攻推迟了几年，但没过多久，维京人和丹麦人又回来了。而且我认为有理由说，维京人崛起的因素之一很可能是法兰克人直接侵入了斯堪的纳维亚的边境，就像罗马权力的延伸，
Germany had kind of inspired German militarism and German raids. So the Frankish Empire has a similar effect on the Vikings. Is there not a twist to that, which is that the fact that the Frankish Empire becomes fragmented and power diffused makes it all the more ripe for Viking raids. So you get the Vikings sailing up rivers because they can now because Charlemagne is gone, a strong central authority is gone. They can kind of pick off the different Frankish kingdoms as their targets. Their particular focus is West Francia, so Gaul as was. And yeah, I mean, they sail up the Loire, they sail up the Seine, and it is a king of West Francia, the great-great-grandson of
德国激发了德国的军国主义和德国的袭击。所以法兰克帝国对维京人也产生了类似的影响。难道这里面没有一个转折吗？那就是法兰克帝国变得四分五裂、权力分散，这使得它更加成熟，更容易遭到维京人的袭击。所以你会看到维京人逆流而上，因为他们现在可以了，既然查理曼已经离去，强大的中央权威已经不复存在。他们可以把不同的法兰克王国当作目标逐一击破。他们特别关注的是西法兰克，也就是过去的加利比亚。是的，我的意思是，他们逆卢瓦尔河而上，逆塞纳河而上，正是西法兰克国王，这位伟大的曾曾孙——
Charlemagne, Charles the Simple, who in 911 gives away a substantial chunk of what had been the great kingdom of Neustria, so ruled by Fredegund. But he gives it away to a Viking chieftain and this will become the land of the Northmen, Normandy, so to Rollo. So as in the kingdoms of Britain, so in West Francia, Royal authority disintegrates in the face of these Viking raids. But the heirs of Charlemagne still cling on to the throne of West Francia throughout the ninth century into the 10th century. But then in 987, the great-grandson of Charles the Simple, so the great-great-great-great-grandson of Charlemagne dies without an heir. So there is no heir of Charlemagne now to succeed to the throne of West Francia. And so a king
查理曼的曾曾孙——糊涂查理，在911年将原本属于伟大的纽斯特里亚王国（由弗蕾德贡德统治）的大片土地拱手相让。但他把它送给了一个维京首领，这里将成为北方人的土地——诺曼底，也就是罗洛。正如在英国各王国一样，在西法兰克，王权在维京人的袭击面前土崩瓦解。但查理曼的继承人们在整个9世纪到10世纪期间仍然死死抓住西法兰克的王位不放。然而在987年，糊涂查理的曾孙——查理曼的玄曾孙——无嗣而终。因此，此时已经没有查理曼的后裔能够继承西法兰克的王位了。于是，一个
from a new family emerges and this is Hugh Capet and the Capetians will be the great medieval dynasty that rules a kingdom that is no longer called West Francia, but France. And of course, in the long run, it's the name that will be given to Louis XVI after he's deposed by the revolutionaries. So you could say that it's with the extinction of the Carolingians, the emergence of this new dynasty, the Capetians, that maybe West Francia becomes France. Yep. The Carolingian line is now extinct. The Frankish line is now extinct in what had been West Frankia. So what about Lotharingia, which is the name given to the
来自新家族的国王崭露头角，这就是于格·卡佩，而卡佩王朝将成为中世纪伟大的王朝，统治一个不再被称为西法兰克、而是被称为法国的王国。当然，从长远来看，这也是路易十六在被革命者废黜后被赋予的名字。所以你可以说，随着加洛林王朝的消亡、这个新王朝卡佩王朝的崛起，西法兰克也许才真正成为了法国。是的。在曾经的西法兰克，加洛林家族现在已经绝嗣了。法兰克家族现在也已经绝嗣了。那么洛泰林贾呢？也就是那个由
great central tranche of lands that have been ruled by Lotha and East Frankia? There too, the lines of Charlemagne go extinct. So the Lotharingian kings, they have inherited the title of emperor, but it's pathetic. I mean, it's a spectral thing. They have no authority. They rule as phantisms. And in 901, the last of these Lotharingian kings to be crowned as emperor, I mean, is treated as an absolute joke. And four years after his coronation, he's captured by a rival warlord. He's blinded and he's banished to a monastery in Burgundy, where for the rest of his life, he just kind of withers away. And of course, there's another irony here is that this is pretty much the fate that Pepin, the first Carolingian king had visited on the last Merovingian king.
洛泰尔和东法兰克统治的伟大中央土地？在那里，查理曼的血脉也绝嗣了。因此，洛泰林贾的国王们虽然继承了皇帝的头衔，但这很可悲。我的意思是，这是一种虚幻的东西。他们没有任何权威。他们像幽灵一样统治着。901年，最后一位被加冕为皇帝的洛泰林贾国王，我的意思是，被当成了一个绝对的笑话。在他加冕四年后，他被一个敌对的军阀俘虏了。他被弄瞎了双眼，并被流放到勃艮第的一家修道院里，在那里度过余生，只是慢慢枯萎消逝。当然，这里还有另一个讽刺，那就是这几乎就是丕平（第一位加洛林国王）强加给最后一位墨洛温国王的命运。
So what goes around comes around. Yeah, there's a lot of blinding in this series. Let's be frank about it. So what about the East Francia, Tom? The last bit. Tom McAllister This witness is the biggest irony of all, because the lands in East Francia, these include, as we said, Saxony. And in 911, the last descendant of Charlemagne to rule East Francia dies without a child. And so there is no descendant of Charlemagne to rule them. And so the lords of East Francia, they still want a Frank and so they elect the Duke of Franconia, which as its name suggests is still a Frankish duchy. And this is a guy called Conrad. And I think the main credential he has is precisely that he is a Frank, but he doesn't last long. 919, so he's ruled for what? Eight years.
所以因果报应，轮回不爽。是的，这个系列里有很多弄瞎眼睛的桥段。我们直说吧。那么东法兰克呢，汤姆？最后一部分。汤姆·麦卡利斯特 这见证了最大的讽刺，因为东法兰克的土地，正如我们所说，包括萨克森。911年，统治东法兰克的最后一位查理曼后裔无嗣而终。因此，没有查理曼的后裔来统治他们了。于是东法兰克的领主们仍然想要一个法兰克人，所以他们选举了法兰克尼亚公爵，正如其名，这仍然是一个法兰克公国。这个人叫康拉德。我认为他拥有的主要资历恰恰在于他是一个法兰克人，但他并没有坚持多久。919年，他统治了多久？八年。
He's severely injured in a battle. He's stretched off the battlefield, brought to bed, and it's clear he's going to die. So on his deathbed, he gets all the noblemen and advisors around him and he says, look, you should give the royal title to a duke called Henry, Heinrich, who had been a perennial rival of Conrad's. But Conrad, as he faces death, he wants to do right by his kingdom and he can recognise that Henry is by miles the ablest man, the man who is best qualified to hold the kingdom together. And so Henry is duly elected as king and messengers are sent out to tell him. And according to tradition, these messengers find Henry fixing birding nests
他在一场战役中身受重伤。他被抬出战场，卧床不起，显而易见他快要死了。所以在临终前，他把所有的贵族和谋士召集在身边说，听着，你们应该把王位授予一位名叫亨利（海因里希）的公爵，他曾是康拉德的死对头。但康拉德临死前想要对他的王国负责，他看出亨利无疑是最能干的人，是最有资格把王国凝聚在一起的人。于是亨利顺理成章地被选为国王，并派信使去通知他。根据传统，这些信使找到亨利时，他正在修理鸟巢，
and so he is known by posterity as Henry the Fowler. Henry the Fowler does indeed prove to be an excellent king. Conrad had read his man correctly, and he in turn has a son, Otto, and Otto proves to be an even more impressive king than his father. So Otto inherits the throne in 962 and he scores up a whole list of achievements that are very, very reminiscent of the great days of the Carolingian Empire, of the Frankish Empire. In 955, there's a massive invasion by pagan Hungarians, which seems to threaten the entire future of beast and Christendom. Otto leads his mailed horsemen to the rescue and it's all Lord of the Rings, riders of Rohan descending onto the fields
所以后世称他为捕鸟者亨利。捕鸟者亨利确实证明自己是一位优秀的国王。康拉德没有看错人，而他反过来也有一个儿子奥托，奥托证明了自己是一位比他父亲更令人印象深刻的国王。因此，奥托在962年继承了王位，并取得了一系列非常令人联想起加洛林帝国、法兰克帝国鼎盛时期的成就。955年，异教徒匈牙利人进行了大规模入侵，这似乎威胁到了整个野蛮人基督教世界的未来。奥托率领他身披铠甲的骑兵前去救援，这一切就像《指环王》中洛汗骑兵冲下佩兰诺尔平原一样。
of Pelennor. Otto smashes them up, saves Christendom. The Hungarians are wiped out and in due course, their remnants will be converted to Christianity and a victory fit to rank with that of Charles Martel at tour. Otto's reward for this in 962 is to be crowned in Rome by the Pope as emperor. So just as Charlemagne had been, and in due course after his death, just as Charlemagne was, Otto is remembered as the great. So Otto the great. So in that sense, I don't think there's any doubt that Charlemagne does have an heir and that heir is Otto the Great and the line of emperors that Otto establishes. And that line, unlike the line that has been established by Charlemagne, will endure unbroken for centuries and centuries and centuries, right the way up to the time of Napoleon, who gets rid of this Holy Roman Empire, as it's come to be called. But of
奥托击溃了他们，拯救了基督教世界。匈牙利人被彻底消灭，不久之后，他们的残余势力也将皈依基督教，这场胜利足以与查理·马特在图尔的胜利相媲美。奥托在962年因此获得的奖赏是在罗马由教皇加冕为皇帝。正如查理曼曾经做过的那样，在他死后不久，就像查理曼一样，奥托也被人们永远铭记为“大帝”。也就是奥托大帝。所以从这个意义上说，毫无疑问查理曼确实有一个继承人，那个继承人就是奥托大帝以及奥托建立的皇帝世系。而且这个世系，不像查理曼建立的那条世系，将延续数百年甚至上千年而没有中断，一直延续到拿破仑时代，拿破仑废除了这个后来被称为神圣罗马帝国的庞然大物。但是
course, this is where the irony comes in because where did Henry the Fowler and Otto the Great come from? Of which portion of East Francia were they the Duke? And the answer is Saxony. The very people that Charlemagne had been smiting. Absolutely. So you could say this is proof that the policy of correctio had worked, that Charlemagne's military efforts, that the efforts of Christian school men and evangelists had succeeded so brilliantly that the true heirs of the Franks were actually the Saxons in exactly the same way that the Franks had been the heirs of the Romans. So just on the Franks, you say just in the same way the Franks are the heirs of the Romans. The idea of the Romans obviously lived on.
当然，这就是讽刺之处，因为亨利一世和奥托大帝是从哪里来的呢？他们曾是东法兰克的哪一部分公爵？答案是萨克森。正是查理曼曾经严厉打击过的人。完全正确。所以你可以说，这证明了“矫正”政策是有效的，查理曼的军事努力、基督教学者和传教士的努力取得了如此辉煌的成功，以至于法兰克斯人的真正继承人实际上就是萨克森人，这与法兰克斯人曾是罗马人的继承人如出一辙。所以就法兰克斯人而言，你刚才说，就像法兰克斯人是罗马人的继承人一样。罗马人的理念显然延续了下来。
So people saw themselves as the heirs of kind of Romanitas, Rome still denoted, a kind of prestige, sophistication, high culture, Christianity, of course. And you know, we're still so familiar with kind of Roman models, Roman togas with their statues and their architecture in Washington DC, to give you an obvious example. But what happened to the Franks? Because obviously, Frank here, France, but in Germany, do they claim particularly culturally to the legacy of the Franks? I would guess not so much. There's still Franconia, I guess. There's still Franconia and Nuremberg. I think the Franks, as a coherent people, kind of dissolve rather like Charlemagne's Empire does.
因此，人们视自己为某种“罗马性”的继承人，罗马仍然象征着某种声望、成熟、高雅文化，当然还有基督教。你知道的，我们依然对各种罗马模式非常熟悉，比如华盛顿特区雕塑和建筑中的罗马托加袍，就是一个明显的例子。但法兰克斯人怎么了？因为显而易见，这里的“法兰克”变成了法国，但在德国，他们是否在文化上声称自己继承了法兰克斯人的遗产？我猜大概没有那么多。我猜还有法兰克尼亚。还有法兰克尼亚和纽伦堡。我认为法兰克斯人作为一个凝聚力强的民族，就像查理曼帝国的命运一样，最终消融了。
Yeah. And that, I think, is what gives their empire its sense of insubstantiality. It's because we know that they ultimately will vanish from the pages of history. I think that's why they are less well known than perhaps they might. Often people have a sense that there's the Roman Empire and then there's the Middle Ages and it's all castles and knights and things. And quite what lies in between is hard to get a handle on. And I think that reflects the fact that the Franks do kind of basically vanish. But of course there is one further irony, which is that by the Greeks, by the Muslims, Otto the Great and his heirs, and in fact the kings of France, and in fact all Latin Christians will be known as Franks. And the episode that we did, what,
是的。我认为，正是这一点赋予了他们的帝国一种虚无缥缈的感觉。这是因为我们知道他们最终会从历史的篇章中消失。我认为这就是为什么他们不如人们想象的那么知名。通常人们会有一种印象，觉得先是罗马帝国，然后是中世纪，到处都是城堡、骑士之类的事物。而介于这两者之间的东西却很难把握。我认为这反映了一个事实，即法兰克斯人确实基本上消失了。但当然，还有一个更深层的讽刺，那就是对于希腊人、穆斯林、奥托大帝及其继承人，事实上还有法国国王，以及所有的拉丁基督徒来说，他们都被称为法兰克斯人。而我们在之前那一期节目中——
kind of 700 episodes ago about the origins of the Franks, we began with people in Thailand calling Black Americans Black Franks. And that reflects the fact that in Baghdad, in the cities of the Caliphate, the memory of Charlemagne and the Frankish Empire endures. And so when they meet with Latin Christians, Muslims call these people Franks. And that's a word that then ripples out from the Near East, out across Asia, to Thailand, to China, wherever. And so in that sense, the Franks do still exist. We are the Franks. Lots of our listeners will be Franks. All that endures really is the name. And I wonder whether part of that is because the Franks themselves felt themselves to be so much in the shadow of Rome, and they were trying to revive something and they saw themselves as the heir to something
大概在700集前关于法兰克斯人起源的节目里，我们以泰国人称呼黑人美国人为“黑法兰克斯人”开篇。这反映了一个事实：在巴格达，在哈里发国的城市里，查理曼和法兰克帝国的记忆得以保存。因此，当他们与拉丁基督徒相遇时，穆斯林会将这些人称为法兰克斯人。这个词随后从近东扩散开来，穿过亚洲，到达泰国、中国以及其他地方。从这个意义上说，法兰克斯人确实仍然存在。我们就是法兰克斯人。我们的许多听众也将是法兰克斯人。真正延续下来的其实只有这个名字。我想知道，部分原因是否在于法兰克斯人自身觉得自己深深笼罩在罗马的阴影之下，他们试图复兴某些东西，并视自己为某种比自身更伟大的事物的继承者
greater than themselves. And so it's the Roman-ness has so much more traction than Frankishness does. All that we remember are the Franks now are their names, right? I don't think that's how the Franks themselves would have seen it, but I think that that is the effect that because the Franks identify themselves with the Roman inheritance so effectively, the potency of that Roman inheritance tends to blot out what was Frankish about them. I think that's right. Okay, well, a tremendous festive episode, the end of a mighty, mighty series, Tom, an epic series taking us from the final years of the Roman Empire, Julian the Apostate, all the way through to medieval Christendom and Otto the Great. So absolutely tremendous sweep. Happy
因此，“罗马性”比“法兰克性”更有吸引力。我们现在对法兰克斯人的所有记忆都只剩下他们的名字了，对吗？我不认为法兰克斯人自己会这么看，但我认为这确实产生了一种效果：由于法兰克斯人如此有效地将自己与罗马遗产联系在一起，罗马遗产的力量往往掩盖了他们身上属于法兰克人的特质。我想是的。好吧，这是一场极其欢乐的节日节目，一个伟大系列的终结，汤姆，这是一部史诗般的系列，带领我们从罗马帝国的最后几年、叛教者尤里安，一直走到中世纪的基督教世界和奥托大帝。所以这是一次绝对宏大的全景回顾。祝大家
Christmas everybody. We will be back at the turn of the year, won't we, Tom? So we will be ringing in the new year with the sound of Mozart and Beethoven. That's very exciting. So we will be bringing you two special episodes with music from the Royal Albert Hall as we celebrate the lives of arguably the two greatest composers of all time, and then nothing says the new year and a bright new start than scenes of life from 1930s Germany. And we will be back after Mozart and Beethoven with the Nazis. And actually, if you're thinking, I know it is Christmas day, so you
圣诞快乐。我们将在新年之交回来，对吧，汤姆？所以我们将伴随着莫扎特和贝多芬的音乐迎接新年的到来。这非常令人兴奋。因此，我们将为您带来两期特别节目，其中包含来自皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅的音乐，以庆祝可以说是史上最伟大的两位音乐家的生平，接下来，没有什么比20世纪30年代德国的生活场景更能代表新年和崭新的开始了。在莫扎特和贝多芬之后，我们将带着纳粹题材回归。实际上，如果你在想——我知道今天是圣诞节，所以
might think the moment has passed, but if you're trying to think of a present to cheer yourself up to mark the new year, what better gift than membership of the Rest is History club, which you can of course join at therestishistory.com. And even if you don't want to treat yourself, I think it would be a kind gesture to treat somebody close to you. Don't you, Tom? Glorious. Christmas ever commercial.
你可能会觉得时机已过，但如果你正试图寻找一件礼物来让自己振作精神、迎接新年，还有什么比加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部（The Rest is History club）更好的礼物呢？当然，你可以在 therestishistory.com 上加入。即使你不想对自己好一点，我想善待你身边的人也是一种贴心的举动，你不觉得吗，汤姆？辉煌的。史上最棒的圣诞商业广告。
Brilliant. Wishing everyone, all of you a very happy Christmas and we'll see you for Mozart and Beethoven and then in the New Year. Bye bye. Bye bye. Hello everybody, Dominic Sandbrook here. And I'm Tom Holland and we have some incredibly exciting news to tell you, don't we Dominic? We do. So we often say we've got exciting news, but this is genuinely very, very exciting news. We are thrilled to announce that after the sellout show that we did earlier this year,
太棒了。祝大家圣诞快乐，我们将在莫扎特和贝多芬的节目中以及新年与大家相见。再见。再见。大家好，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。我是汤姆·霍兰德，我们有一些非常令人兴奋的消息要告诉大家，对吧，多米尼克？是的。所以我们经常说我们有令人兴奋的消息，但这绝对是极其令人兴奋的消息。我们非常高兴地宣布，继今年早些时候我们那场门票售罄的演出之后，
The Rest is History will be returning to the Royal Albert Hall on Sunday the 4th of May to perform live once again with an orchestra. And we will be bringing you a brand new show and this time discussing two more of history's most extraordinary, fascinating and iconic classical composers, in this case Tchaikovsky and Wagner. And these extraordinary lives will be brought to life thanks to the accompaniment of the renowned Philharmonia Orchestra conducted by the celebrated Oliver Zefferman.
《历史其余部分》将于5月4日星期日重返皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅，再次与交响乐团同台献艺。我们将为您带来一场全新的演出，这一次我们将讨论两位历史上面最非凡、迷人且最具标志性的古典音乐家，他们是柴可夫斯基和瓦格纳。在著名的爱乐乐团的伴奏下，在著名指挥家奥利弗·泽费曼的指挥下，这些非凡的生命历程将被生动地呈现在舞台上。
So that first show that we did this year was a truly glorious experience. And we are hoping that this too will be an unforgettable night. There'll be great music, we'll be telling great stories, we'll be delving into the history. So you had better get your hands on tickets for the show as soon as you can. And these tickets will be available from www.royalalberthall.com on Thursday the 19th of December with a pre-sale
因此，我们今年举办的第一场演出是一次真正光荣的体验。我们希望这一次也将是一个难忘的夜晚。会有美妙的音乐，我们会讲述伟大的故事，我们还会深入探讨历史。所以你最好尽快买到这场演出的门票。这些门票将于12月19日星期四在 www.royalalberthall.com 上发售，而“历史其余部分”俱乐部成员以及皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅的朋友和赞助商则可以提前24小时，
for the Rest is History Club members and Royal Albert Hall friends and patrons 24 hours earlier on Wednesday the 18th of December at 10 a.m. That is the rest is history live with the Philharmonia Orchestra Tchaikovsky and Wagner. It's at the Royal Albert Hall on Sunday the 4th of May. Now the tickets are available for members on Wednesday the 18th of December and for the general public on Thursday the 19th of December and please make sure that you don't miss it. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
即在12月18日星期三上午10点进行优先购票。这就是“历史其余部分”与爱乐乐团联袂呈现的现场演出：柴可夫斯基与瓦格纳。演出将于5月4日星期日在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅举行。门票将于12月18日星期三面向会员发售，12月19日星期四面向公众发售，请千万不要错过。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。